[Music]
Kev Kev good to see you man Tim Tim look
at this In the Flesh in the flesh like
grown-ups sitting at a table in Austin
cheers man look at this we're together
love it happy Holidays happy Holidays
happy early New Year's I
suppose
was I supposed to shoot that no it's
quite good that's sipping this is
sipping yeah so this is something that
I've had on previous random shows but I
don't think I've talked about it too
much this is L tequila and lo tequila
full disclosure it's my first and only
alcohol rated investment I was first
introduced to this at a fantastic
restaurant here in Austin called swerte
excellent restaurant and I feel like
you've talked about this this place
before it's great it's maybe I should go
there tonight an excellent restaurant
was it hard to get in or no not too not
too bad and there is typically some
walk-in available they reserve some
space for walk-ins sweet and I went
there for the first time with Chase
Jarvis Chase and I had not seen Chase in
ages he was coming in from out of town
wanted to do something text Mexi ended
up at swerte and we wanted to have
tequila because we both both like
tequila asked what the server most
recommended recommended something I'd
never heard of this L and I ended up
really liking it both of us bought a
bottle turns out that the namesake so Lo
is the grandson of Don Julio oh crazy
and this is additive free it is matured
in the plant instead of in barrels so
it's a Blanco only Blanco they don't
sell anything non- Blanco and they
harvest from more mature plants so for
for a lot of the large larger scale
operations they harvest one could argue
prematurely and then they try to add a
little razzled dazzle with additives and
the way that they use the barrels and
instead of doing that they're letting
the plant do the work so this particular
tequila for me at least is a very clean
drink and I know this is a topic dour of
course alcohol no alcohol I certainly
find a place for it and then about 6
months n mon month later a year later
out of the blue a friend of mine reached
out who does a lot of cpg so consumer
package good stuff he's a genius when it
comes to both operating and investing
he's one of the best I've ever seen and
he said I'm not sure if you've ever
heard of this particular brand but would
you have any interest in looking at La
and I was like yes I would because I
drink it all the time and that's how it
came together that that was going to be
my question for you because I I feel
like so many of us have had something
that we've used in life and said gosh I
wish I was an investor here like have
you done that with multiple companies
has there been something where you've
said this is so great I have to invest
and then if so what is your strategy to
get to that point where you can become
friends with the founder talk about
around you are better at doing this than
I am you're one of the best I've seen
back when Twitter was usable sorry but I
remember Twitter and you you've used
pretty much every channel available
you're very generous and sincere when
you find something you love you share it
add value first yes and you are able to
get the attention of Founders
historically I've seen you do this over
and over again and often I'll do that so
these days for me if I find something
and I will sometimes look at either my
credit card statement or the stuff I use
the most and run down the list to see if
there's anything I might want to invest
in for instance and there are a few That
Got Away there are a bunch that got away
right like one password I should have
and I knew the guys and they ended up
raising money maybe a year or two ago
like a jillion dollars massive great
guys and I'm like ah if I had just and I
didn't want to soz it didn't feel right
but if I had pushed just a little bit
more maybe could have done something
there are many stories like that that I
could tell but these days I would say I
try to be helpful so I will take
something and if it's good I'm like look
even if I don't end up being involved
with the company MH I want to help him
out the product fantastic so I might put
it in the newsletter I might mention it
on the podcast do something like that
yeah one of the things that you hear
these stories every once in a while I
remember when Facebook was getting off
the ground Zuck wanted a mural painted
you know the story and I do but you
should tell it anyway the artist
actually at that time said you know
don't pay me in cash pay me in stock and
and that's often times a very good
strategy where you say hey I might not
have the capital to go invest in this
thing but I have a skill and that skill
is somehow going to be useful to this
company if I can make friends with them
then at some point you know it's not
it's like let's share the upside
together totally you know and you can
you don't have to ask for a big massive
percentage but you can say hey can I is
there some options available that I can
have and that can work I mean for that
guy I think it turned him into like a
billionaire or something like that
something crazy at least several hundred
million dollars David show who's
fascinating he has done some incredible
and hilarious things he's a very funny
guy very very creative I don't know but
I've heard that story so many times he
had a podcast called I think it was
dvda double vag double anal with Wow Asa
Akira who's a porn star and I it might
have all been taken down but he is a
polymath he's an incredible artist
incredible actor also that could have
been the name of your show remember
tried to come up with names for your
show instead of Tim Tim talk talk
exactly you know was a close runner up
we all have to make we all have to make
decisions I saw a shirt side note well
I've had one sip of tequil and here we
go already I saw a shirt at a climbing
gym yesterday which said no Solutions
only tradeoffs and I was like that is
actually pretty interesting to sit with
but on the advising front because that's
really what we're talking about
right where can people learn more about
that because I used to point people and
maybe this is still a good reference
it's a little dated but Venture hacks
used to have a bunch on advisors and
super
advisors this is worth
unpacking a little bit for folks so if
you look at for instance my track record
the vast majority of my lifetime
earnings and startups have actually come
from
advising and that's not to say that it's
easy that's not to say that times
haven't changed because certainly times
have changed since 2008 2009 2010 but if
you have a skill or you have a network
or you have a
platform there are times when it will be
appealing for both both you and for
startup to have some type of trade for
Equity right
and Saka used to be fantastic at this
before before he became the Chris Saka
Mary lights that we know and love today
yeah and taught me a lot about this but
you might look for let's just say I
don't know how the landscape has changed
you could you could probably speak to
this but say 0
2.25% right so yeah like a quarter point
seen the compan pretty early super early
and the way that that's drisk for the
company or one way that that can be D
drisk is that it vests over a course of
say two years right so every
quarter a percentage of that basically
becomes yours yeah and the company can
cancel at any time yeah and that allows
them in a sense to kind of try before
they fully buy right they get to see
what results you can deliver any other
thoughts on folks or thoughts on folks
Jesus one tip in well this is related to
to caffeine which we're going to come
back to at some point so it's important
to remember that every company that's
out there private company when they're
forming and putting together their cap
table like their list of investors
employees all of that they put together
something called an options pool which
is a percentage of the company that is
used to incentivize those employees to
work there and so when you join a
company you get X number of options and
you earn them over say typically 3 to
four years mhm a part of that most
Founders will set aside for advisors and
so these are people that not are not
compensated with money but rather just
stock and so in my mind what I always do
when I'm forming a new company is I say
okay I'm going to take 1% and I'm going
to carve that into 10 roles and then I'm
going to go out there and find the 10
most impactful people that I can
possibly find to help me change the
outcome of this this company and you
offer them in a role and you say hey no
fancy strings attached so I never say to
be an advisor you have to tweet X number
of times like screw that like you want
it to come from a place of authenticity
and so you know and you're often doing
this with people you know presumably
right or or you can find someone that
you're just like this is a really good
match like you know I I there's an AI
company that uh I've been working with
and they needed someone that had a very
specific expertise in a very small
subset of a type of AI and they found an
advisor and they didn't know this person
but they reached out it never starts
with hey we want to offer you an
advisory role it's a coffee it's a
hangout it's a dinner it's let's get to
know each other it's like hey you might
be helpful and sometimes they'll say no
actually you can hire me as a contractor
but or it's a mix mixture of both you
can say Hey you know we'll bring you on
as a contractor for three months and
we'll give you an advisory role so
there's no perfect science here but just
expect to get some fraction of 1% of a
company as an adviser and your hope is
that this turns into you know a 10000
$500 million company
and that becomes you know a very
lucrative outcome for you mhm and I
would imagine part of the reason that
you're comfortable not having a laundry
list of deliverables is because their
advisor Equity vests over a period of
time yeah it vest over a period of time
you can cancel it any time so if you're
three months in you're like ah this
person's not doing anything you can just
cancel it and you know no hard feelings
everybody just they get a little a small
percentage of that you know and that's
fine yeah I would say that it's best in
my mind not to over complicate things
especially with celebrities celebrities
don't want to have like some type of
crazy you know 20page document they have
to run by their agent and they have to
go through with their attorneys and they
have to figure out oh I'm going to have
to show up at this event like screw all
that like if you work with a celebrity
and you find someone you happen to know
someone and they want to be an advisor
say no strings attached oh by the way
we're doing this party in two months you
can come or not right and often times
that actually frees them up to be like I
don't feel feel like I'm a being used as
a pawn here sure I'll show up for a half
hour or 45 minutes and that's a win for
you right you want them to speak from
the heart when they're talking about a
product I think you would agree that
time kills deals right like deals do not
get better with time especially if
you're dealing with someone who has an
Entourage or like a fance of lawyers
managers agents Etc you want it to be an
easy yes make it an easy yes 100% I so
I'll give you an example back in the day
you know when I launched Moon Bird's
that pfp the nft project that I launched
I talked to a handful of people and some
people that that I knew quite well that
were you know very famous celebrities
there's one NBA player that is you know
Hall of Famer that I gifted a moonbird
to and I said Hey listen he's like I'm
web 3 curious I want to learn more about
you know web 3 and it's job like you
know you know yeah so I gave him one and
I said sweetheart of a guy too super
nice guy and I said to him I said listen
you don't have to tweet about it like
that's this isn't a pay for play thing I
would never want to do that if for some
reason down the road you think it's
really cool and you want to say
something you can and he never tweeted
about it so but no but that's fine you
know cuz like he did just wasn't vibing
with it didn't feel that it was going in
the right direction or whatever it may
be and same thing for Jimmy Fallon you
know Jimmy was super kind super nice and
he created a little parody account for
his Moon birds and was tweeting from it
and he was figuring out because he
wanted to learn web 3 wallets he set up
his own wallet he nested his own meaning
he interacted with smart contracts and
alls and it was because he was curious
on the tech side and there was no money
exchange there was no like there was
nothing about it wasn't about that so
that that's the way I like to do these
types of
deals and you tell me if this resonates
with you I would also think in terms of
whether you're building a company or an
adviser who would I like to work with on
multiple companies because I've seen for
instance in many of the cases where I've
been an adviser assuming you do a decent
slash good job
a lot of these people if they're good
are going to be serial entrepreneurs
right and then you end up just advising
advising advising and they have their
X-Men Squad that they pull in to most
startups yeah that seems to me to be
pretty common yeah absolutely I mean I
think there's certain domain experts
when you think about like just
strategies around different parts of
your business where you say gosh I would
always want this person in my corner if
I'm going to go launch a consumer
internet product right and so you go
back to those people or if who don't
know like a great example is you know
I'm relaunching my podcast in January
and one of the things that I just have
been out of loop on is a Tik Tok
strategy and I just really found a a
great company that had been recommended
and had you know worked with multiple
top 20 kind of podcasts on their Tik Tok
strategy because I that's that's a hole
that's missing right and so I'm going to
go out I ask like 10 friends who's the
best the best at this and then try and
hone in on that person or people and
then get them to you know work on your
behalf and in this particular case I'm
paying them for it but that's fine I
think twerking is the answer coordinated
dances and twerking you might have a
little what you do for your advisory
yeah a little case of werewolf buns I
don't know if that's uh if that's a plus
or a minus on on Tik Tok January yeah
January let's talk about January we're
coming up on the New Year how are you
thinking about New Year's resolutions
that type of thing yeah so we do this
every year like we do I don't even want
to go revisit our list cuz I'm sure
they're horrible what do you think your
hit rate is on on your previous list you
had it written down do you have your
last list can you look at I don't have
it in front of me right now I would say
that over the years I've become better
my hit rate is higher 50% yeah I would
say it's 50% I'd say it's probably 50%
which hey if that were startup investing
man you'd be best of the best right
yeah but you also don't want to set your
resolutions like brush my teeth three
times a week you don't want to set the
bar so low just for checking the box
right uh so I would say it's 50% maybe a
bit more than 50% I think this year
they're simple enough that I could
actually get to 100% yes that's that's
exactly what I did so this year for me
it's about less but make sure I can try
to get to 75 to 100% of them so all
right mine are really straightforward
last year I went one month without
drinking this year my therapist has told
me she's awesome and and she's like
she's like oh you made it a month she's
like oh cool cool like congrats
everybody does that and I'm like she's
like a little bit like a hard ass and I
kind of like that about her yeah and
she's like no go three months she's like
that's when the real benefits start to
show up is at three months and I'm like
could you I mean you could have said two
but so she that three I'm going to go
three months without drinking that's a
big one for me daily meditation has
obviously have been a big part of my
life I'm going to continue that Trend we
can talk about Henry schikman new app
too which is going to be a big part of
that zen master that I study under is
finally launching a new meditation app
coming in January called the way and
very excited to help him with that app
in terms of like on the product side and
just usability side obviously he's doing
all the content I'm not involved in it
I'm just investor in it but not involved
in content not involved in content right
yeah I'm not as Z Master you but you
know you've studied very seriously with
Henry yeah for a few years you
introduced us he's been on this podcast
twice and they're very strong episodes
so I encourage people to check those out
out what makes the way different so the
the one thing about you know as an
investor so I'm a part-time VC because I
have this other you know nft and art
thing on that I'm working on as well as
a VC over true we are looking for novel
ideas things that haven't been done
before and the meditation app market is
just completely saturated saturated like
there's there's who would want to build
an app in that space it's like it's
there's I mean comm's dominating you
know head space face dominating like you
know waking up fantastic app for more on
the depth side I would say sam probably
brings together the strongest group of
teachers I would say is a portfolio of
meditation teach like a university of
meditation yeah exactly so Henry is his
approach is like you know if you go into
any of these other meditation apps it's
like a meditation for sleep a meditation
for anxiety and meditation for this
three minute meditation two-minute
meditation 30 second meditation you know
it's like it's all these different is
like he's very humble but he's one of
only I think three fully accredited Zen
Masters in his lineage of Zen in the
United States and he is bringing Zen uh
a flavor of Zen mixed in with some other
types of meditation and his goal is is
simple there's it's it's the way it's
one path there there's no Choose Your
Own Adventure it's not it's it's not the
ways yeah it's not the ways right
there's you can't Branch off and do a
body scan over here and then come back
for a sleep meditation or a sleep story
like it's none of that that is a
singular path and his goal is to lead
you to some type of Awakening moment
sometime in the future so it's for those
that are like okay I've tried the other
meditation apps I want to go deep I want
I want to get really serious about this
so I can't tell you when it's going to
launch they're in beta right now I can't
tell you that the way app.com is going
to be the place where you can put in
your email address and I'll let you know
when you know what we can do for your
show notes let's put a beta link cuz I
think you can have up to a thousand
testers put it in your show notes and
get a bunch of people testing it out
lovely yeah we'll put it tim. blogcast
you put a little bit of cash in too
which is great I did which was going to
be what I was going to say next which is
this is my first investment in a
meditation app and my first investment
in any type of consumer app in a while
in fact and that's based on my
interactions nevere you know which
wasn't I that wasn't a bad thing that
was that was certainly not it didn't
turn into the thousand X you know 10,000
x return that I would like they turned
it around it's a good product again it
is a good product I still use it believe
it or not dude I don't this is actually
on my my my list we'll get into that but
yeah finish your thoughts well I was
just going to say that I learned so much
about product I learned so much about
startups I learned so much about scaling
what to do what not to do through my
experience with that company where I was
an adviser because I didn't have the
capital early on to really build out a
large portfolio with cash
alone and I was able to request this is
not a small thing for me I was able to
make requests of product changes
directly it's amazing that Lifeline the
CEO that Lifeline the CEO and to the
product team for me selfishly if I'm
using an app every day that makes a
difference to my quality of life so I I
do not regret it and part of your
Calculus if you're going to be involved
with early stage has to be I think the
assumption that the vast majority are
not not going to return what you hope
they're going to return out of 10 fa
that's that's just part of a power law
distribution great book by the way power
law so New Year's resolutions what are
your what else do you have and and do
you have a date I'm just going to hold
your feet to the fire a little bit for
your three months have you decided on a
start date oh so I've got I'm going to
invite you to this my my birthday's in
February and you're invited I I got
really lucky to get to know the artist
son so do you know at all stuff oh so
good so s has become a nice friend and
he agreed to come play my birthday party
for like 30 people amazing and so he's
going to fly out he's in Spain right now
he's going to fly out and and play and I
got to have a couple drinks there we're
going to have a little bar I got yeah
that would be a you'd be failing before
you started it if your first day were
the day before your birthday yes after
my birthday is when I'm going to kick
this off so that'll be good but yeah so
really quickly to hit on mine so no
drinks for three months daily meditation
Nob brainer
I want to organize my brain I want to in
digital form and so this is what's
really interesting in the last 3
months multiple notet taking apps have
enabled Ai and what they're doing now is
they're saying
screw knowing where your notes are ask
questions of your Corpus of data so it's
changing into a world where you can just
enter all the data enter all of Tim's
brain into some place and say hey what
was that one note I had that one time
when I was at that Mexican restaurant
and I think it was about cat beds like
and and and it will literally serve you
up that note based on the AI and its
crawling abilities and I think that's
just fascinating so notion has added
that there are three you know they call
them second brain note taking apps that
that are really four that I'm
considering I'm still working through
all of them to see which one I like the
best my candidates are notion craft is
amazing craft is a really beautiful app
it's a little bit more about here's the
current day start taking notes and then
you can interconnect the notes and do
all kinds of fun things there is it
spelled like the dictionary word spelled
like craft cheese no c yeah craft uh
obsidian is another one if you heard of
of obsidian I've heard of it or maybe I
just like the name it's more like graph
based interconnected nodes like all
these backlinks you know tying together
thoughts and ideas uh you know kind of
my brain you've seen these cloud
mappings of of interconnected notes note
making apps and services also a very
crowded Market very crowded mhm and
capacities is the last one I'm looking
at I'm leaning towards craft I think
that's probably my going to be my go-to
It won app of the year last year on iOS
okay and it's uh it's it's pretty
fantastic so and I will say in that list
and still actually I think the largest
market share barely bidding out notion
is Evernote still and so I installed
Evernote the latest version I'm like
damn this is actually a lot better I
thought for a minute there it was going
to go under I was like cuz it trained
hands a little bit there was a little
bit of drama there yeah and but got
overly Diversified overextended yeah but
it's quite good they've revamped the app
and it's it's it's nice so that in
launching my podcast and so just keep it
as simple launching the Kevin Rose show
which is Kevin rose.com if you want to
sign up I'll let you know when it
launches but I got some great guest
lined up for that show and taking it
seriously building out a real Studio
doing it professionally professional
editors the the whole thing so it's
gonna be great it is gonna be great I
can't wait to see I want to keep it
simple though the not 10 things but like
just like three or four yeah what are
yours mine are and then I'm going to
come back don't worry folks it's not
going to consume the whole show but I
want to ask you a question about AI so
I'll I'll preload that in your head
which is where do you think people will
make will compromise their privacy
because of really compelling convenience
where they might regret it I'm just like
where they might click yes in providing
access where later they'll be like oh I
really shouldn't have done that so
that's I have two I two quick answers
for that for one I think is going to be
photos people believe that don't ever
click yes to all photo access
especially if you've got
dickpics just like wow no listen I I
went there because a buddy of mine just
got compromised last
week I I I kid you not I kid you not so
this is a true story I'm not going to
say who this is I swear to you Tim this
is a true story my buddy got Sim swapped
okay somebody took over his iCloud
account uh and he's got a very and my
wife knows this so I can say this freely
he's got he's got a very beautiful wife
and and you know he's a good-looking
dude he's good like yeah solid B you
know kind of like us you know like B
minus whatever and and he's got pictures
of his wife like all in his iCloud like
you know and she's like he's traveling a
lot she's saying
little little naughty naughty yeah and
I'm like I'm like dude are you are you
sending a little back or you know cuz
like those are the ones like no one's
going to complain about your wife
getting leaked online it's like are your
pics going to get out there online and
it was a really stressful few days for
him I am sure honestly not to judge
anyone who's who's fond of shooting
around dickpics I don't understand how
anyone is ends up in that position yeah
I'm just like don't do it there are
certain Commandments it's like Thou
shalt not send dickpics just like the
downside is so much higher than any
possible upside right plus I'm I mean
look maybe I'm bu I'm just like who was
like I don't think I have you know the
Shrek of penises but it's like I don't I
don't understand what the appeal is also
well that's because you don't like
penises I'm not yeah I don't have a like
a collage of schwas made into a piece of
artwork on my wall so maybe maybe that's
it maybe I'm just that's based on the
team I mean it's for for some people
that's kind of their like you know the
way they flirt remotely and things like
that and that's it's not me I don't I
don't do that either but I I think I'm
actually doing a full episode on my
podcast on dick on
dickpic
on on on locking down specifically
iCloud because I think it is the the
scarest place for hackers to gain access
to because they get your iMessage
messages and they also get your your
photos as well but um any any quick tips
for folks just a little teaser yeah I
here's a quick teaser number one thing
you can do is that so you want to hear
the crazy that happened to him no
no this will blow your mind oh God here
we can I paranoia go wasn't a Sim swap
so what happened is is that apple as you
know if you forget your password they
have something called I forgot which is
like you can go there and say I forgot
my password right and and it says okay
well do you have another device that you
can confirm no I don't have another
device okay well what's your backup
phone number right and so you can reset
that password with a backup phone number
that you put into the system that all
makes sense right a Sim swap somebody
steals your phone number and they get
access to it and then that's how you get
compromised their Sim swaps are getting
harder to do because you know some of
the big providers have caught on and
they've tried to kind of like prevent
that from happening ask you more
questions all that nature well someone
called in on his behalf to let's let's
just say because it was you might want
to believe that they sponsor at some
point but they called in they faked like
it was him yeah and they didn't ask for
a Sim swap what they asked for they said
hey can you forward the phone number
just for an hour to this other number
because I need it forwarded so normally
this so it was straight social
engineering no but you straight social
engineering but listen to this normally
a forward wouldn't work because a text
message doesn't get forwarded only calls
do but you can go into apple and you can
say I have auditory problems I can't
hear can you call me with the security
code so they did a quick forward they
called it didn't go to his phone it went
to the Hacker's phone Apple read the
security code to them via audio they put
it in compromise reset it changed his
phone number compromise download all his
data and then tried to blackmail him to
get his data back oh my God okay so in
terms of teasers for yes teaser number
one thing to do is that you want a cell
phone provider where there is not a
phone number to call and it's really
truly securely locked down your best
provider for that in the United States
is Google F and what you do is you don't
set it up with your Google account you
create a brand new Gmail account that no
one knows timtim secure 8537 gmail.com
he just docks me so hard exactly and
then you you two- Factor the off the
crap out of that turn on Google's
Advanced protection there then you sign
up for a Google fly account which is a
brand new phone number then you tell
Apple that is your backup phone number
because Apple can still service your
main number but only use that backup
number to reset passwords so there's no
possible way anyone would know that
backup number and so it's it's a whole
thing there's more steps to it than that
you know you get Hardware Keys involved
like Google's Titan key which is the the
most like hardcore of the USBC you know
Keys Hardware Keys uses one of their
Titan chips which is legit it's a whole
thing but it's scary yeah terrifying
time for me to double down my phone has
been acting funny recently it's making
me spooked a bit it dude it scares the
crap out of me yeah it's like my phone
has been acting a little funny and I'm
like weird you know what sucks to is is
I've been going to Whatsapp more and
doing that seven days like delete all my
messages because honestly there are tell
me if you feel this way I know you feel
this way cuz we have these conversations
on on text
there are things that you say with your
friends that you're just like if anyone
read this out of context I would seem
like the most oh insert whatever oh
every person who uses group threads if
you are remotely interesting or if
you're all and funny you're all
like if anything were made public
everybody's screwed the number of like
jokes I've made that are not something I
would want the world to see but are all
in good fun and just amongst friends
it's like in the thousands right and if
that got online I would deny it all
I didn't write that AI did the
AI but yeah it's it's tough so anyway
this is this is actually really good
tequila it's really smooth so on the AI
front real brief and then oh we said
photos was the one one part you asked
what were the two places where or what
were the places where AI might
compromise your data yes so that's the
first one yeah so I think photos would
be the main thing and then the second
one would be just this idea of these
note-taking apps because if you're
journaling like for me I I have you know
a fantastic therapist and I Journal all
of that right and so things like
obsidian the reason I'm drawn to one
that one in particular is it's local
only so it only doesn't sing to the
cloud and when it does it uses a local
encrypted key so they not even they can
read your data I trust notion I trust
but they if you know someone were to
compromise their key on their end in
theory even though the data is encrypted
at rest meaning like when it's not being
used encrypted on their hard drives is
still a potential vulnerability there so
that that does but at the end of the day
if someone really wants to read my
therapy not it's like whatever you know
we live in a world where you can just be
like ah someone made that
up yeah there's a lot of there's there's
a whole new world of plausible
deniability with AI and there's a whole
new world of exploits to Wild on the AI
side for people who might be curious
I've actually not on my personal notes
but we have trained or I should say
rather automatic which ronw
wordpress.com and I rely on their
Enterprise side of things for all of my
websites they have an AI feature and
they've trained this AI on all of my
transcripts so if you want to ask
questions of 700 or so transcripts of
the Tim Farah show you can do that yep
the results in a lot of cases are
surprisingly good there's several
startups working on this I I saw one
that actually indexed your show and and
if you ask a question of it we'll return
the clip in which you said the the
answer to it which is amazing I was
thinking the other day about you know a
great startup that I don't have the time
to build would be a podcast app that
imagine this world and tell me that this
is interesting to you so it trains on
all of your data I'm listening to Tim
Faris show I'm halfway through an
episode and you mentioned something that
I don't understand or I'm just not
familiar with let's just say iasco for
something random okay and I and I hit
pause and I hit the Tim AI button now
it's trained on your voice so it can
respond in your voice and I say Tim you
know what is iasa actually before we
continue the show and you respond you
say well iwasa is this and I talked
about it in episode number 12 blah blah
blah and also number 27 and here's a
clip of me saying this and then you can
rejoin the stream of the podcast and
continue so it's almost like you show up
as a coach mid podcast for any questions
I have about that show so I can pick
your brain and also as applied to your
books so I could go into your entire
Corpus of books that I have and ask
questions of that data as well that has
to be the future right yeah that's
interesting I how do you feel about it
as a content creator does that make you
a little uneasy it doesn't make me
uneasy on a Content level because I
operate from a place of abundance with
my stuff because my stuff is so dense
right it's not dense necessarily in a
bad way but it's like I could talk about
the content of say one of my books for
hours on dozens of podcasts and not come
close to exhausting even 20% of that
book so I'm very forthcoming with that
the
one flag I I would say that I have for
that particular example is that if it's
my voice and so on and this is going to
come up a lot with AI what is the
indemnity what does liability look like
right if someone uses an ad and they're
like well this Tim AI told me that I
should do ab and C or that I should
right Y and
Z1 you hope per chance they get it wrong
and then as applied to something
dangerous right because that could be
like telling you from the 4-Hour Chef
how to you know make runny eggs the
wrong way who cares but like it's like
telling you to take the wrong supplement
dosage is a whole another can of worms
there's dangerous and then there's just
opportunity for scammers right right
well that's happening regardless well it
is going to be calling me time well not
just on the AI kind of social
engineering side but for instance there
are we don't have to spend a lot of time
on this but there are people called
Career plaintiffs out there
unfortunately I know what this is but
for instance there will be a law firm
what they do is they file class AC
action lawsuits based on a couple and
like you know Barbara and Bob Jones are
the couple that they work with all the
time and they're like hey Barbara and
Bob Subway sandwiches is selling 11 1/2
in Subs but they're calling them foot
long go buy two of them and then
complain with us and we'll file this
thing and we'll give you 10% of The
Upside and I think that some of these AI
models will provide a nice juicy bite of
the Apple that was actually a real
lawsuit by the way that you're
mentioning oh I know
yeah oh I know but we won't get into the
details of why I know that God the US
man some of these things it's it's just
astonishing that that they the rules
provide for some of these creatures to
exist and profit coming back to New
Year's resolutions yeah we had a nice
big Boomerang on that mine are I would
say simple not necessarily easy as is
true with a lot of things the first is
minimalist delegation and what that
means to me is
delegating the why and the who but not
necessarily the the how so I think my
predisposition is to be very detailed
when I delegate various types of or
projects mhm in other words what I would
like to do more of is here is at the
simplest
level five words of what I want to do MH
figure it out right and you can handle
all the specifics you should know that
we should have at least three bids if
we're putting something out that's
expensive dot dot dot dot dot but to
really take my hands off the wheel in
terms of overprescribing the details
which I which I have a tendency to do
because my mind is very detail focused
I'm very meticulous but I found that
more often than not I can point to
examples of where I'm providing too much
step-by-step detail and also people who
receive that in some cases feel like
they're being micromanaged not only that
they're not building the muscle exactly
because they they need to understand
where the only way they can kind of
build that muscle around who you are and
what you want is by making mistakes and
you saying hey I would have done it this
way a little bit differently because of
X Y and Z and then they learn from that
mistake versus you just prescribing it
saves you a ton of time it saves a
ton of time so what I'm what I'm
experimenting with and I've already
started doing this and I think I've made
a lot of progress is say
less say less and be available for
questions but otherwise make it clear
that there's a certain degree of wiggle
room and space for errors that is okay
so when your admin walks in you say
sandwich if meatball sandwich throws you
throw it against the wall and he say
wrong sandwich that would be one
way to handle it and I remember there
was I want to say a blog post a while
ago that was written by either Ben Koka
or Reed Hoffman but B Ben Koka used to
be the let's just call it like Aid to
Camp or chief of staff for Reed Hoffman
and what Reed had said to Ben was
something along the lines and I remember
remember this because I had to look it
up this would be a chance for me to
interrogate like the read AI like what
do you mean by blah blah blah he said in
the service of speed I'm willing to
accept 10% foot faults and I was like
foot faults does that mean and I
think it's a tennis reference which is
like when you step over the line when
you're serving and you get called for a
fault but in the service of speed
basically the way I interpret that is
you can get 10% wrong ideally it's not
really expensive catastrophic stuff but
I'm willing to accept the 10% error rate
in the service of speed so I'm trying to
think about it along those lines because
there's so many things that are either
reversible or inexpensive where it
doesn't really matter yeah doesn't
really matter you're better off making
sort of wrong decision and then right
decision and doing both of those quickly
because you course correct then taking a
ton of time to deliberate in your mind
when often times you don't even have
complete information you don't know but
also like imagine you get that down to
5% the extra effort required what is
that doing to you as a bird
yeah versus just letting go a little bit
and letting those faults happen yeah and
it's got to be a little bit freeing yeah
totally question for you because I
thought you recommended at some point
this book to me and I have two or three
friends who have recommended it since
the surrender experiment yeah are you
still a fan Michael Singer yes yeah I
I'm still a fan I okay could you say a
little bit about it because I don't know
if we've ever talked about it on the
podcast yeah I mean I haven't read it
for probably two and a half or so years
now but Michael Singer is I don't want
to say well spiritual Guru or or more
just kind of like a a salt of the earth
type guy that has figured out that
surrender is kind of the ultimate
Freedom like this idea that you can just
release and let go puts you more in the
present moment than pretty much anything
else and the whole book is around how
when stuff comes in it doesn't hit you
it doesn't hit and stick MH so like to
hit and stick and marinate and INF
Fester is not surrendering it's like
it's letting it the energy build and and
bring you down often times and the book
is framed around this idea that the more
you can let go the more freedom there is
the more happiness there is and as Henry
shookman put it the freedom comes from
not the tight grip on reality but the
slow Finger by finger letting go of that
grip and and part of the appeal for me
as it was described to me I have not
read the book but a very close friend of
mine is reading it right now and he has
a course by the way that's fantastic
okay it's on sounds true it's a video
course and it's it's quite good it's a
video course yeah did you watch the is
it necessary to watch the video or is I
just like he's a he's a quirky
personality and he's great he's great on
video he's just like really funny yeah
and it seems like the that book at least
is his personal story which
automatically makes it more engaging for
me hypothetically all right so yes
letting go so the minimist delegation
and the second point is actually related
to that that is the in a sense letting
go uh quick creative collaborations is
the second one I only have three things
it's minimalist delegation quick
creative collaborations and then
physical reboot which which is pretty
straightforward to me again it's it's
simple but not always easy we got to get
into my physical reboot here in a minute
yeah we're going to talk about it so
quick creative
collaborations this is an area where you
have seen me actually kick the tires
quite a bit in the last year with
punch which by the way there's a ton
coming with that which is going to be a
big surprise to a lot of people but I
have done by punching notes real
quick here by nfts Tim Ferris punch
that's right
hashtag to the moon no not Financial
advice Jesus oh that was AI talking I
didn't say that in the process I mean
using this nft project way back in the
day which is when it launched in
December of 2022 I guess as a vehicle
through which to do creative experiments
right emergent long fiction that was
kind of the whole point I've walked the
walked the talk in the sense that since
then and a lot of this has been
invisible but it will soon be visible
I've done creative Sprints in say
Upstate New York with some of the top
DND and Magic the Gathering artists I
should say people who have done amazing
iconic work for those Brands yeah doing
character design and concept you it was
so much fun it was so much fun and I
have had this narrative that I'm a
better I see right individual
contributor I'm better as a solo
operator and that in in some sense I
think because I've heard from some
Publishers and so on that I'm a bit of a
problem author because I'm very very
very unwilling to compromise quality
like I'm just I am unwilling to
compromise quality and I'm very
meticulous and so if somebody's not on
that same page I'm a problem and so I
developed this narrative that I was just
prickly and difficult and didn't how
much that do you think is true have you
ever done a 360 review I have done a 360
review the feedback doesn't usually I
wouldn't say it supports that narrative
and in this particular
case gathered all these folks had some
writers as well which I thought was
going to be harder than the art side
because I can I can step back and say
you are all much better better at Art
than I am but I have an identity as a
writer and it was great had two writers
three artists and had an absolute blast
the output was spectacular which I
haven't made public yet and that
emboldened me to do more and more
experiments and so I can't talk too much
about it right now but I am actually
working on my First Book Project in
seven years eight years and I'm doing it
with a collaborator which I thought I
would never do in a million years wait
you got to give us a little more fiction
non-fiction nonfiction this is this is
OG TF
Style No No 5 hour but but very dense
hyper tactical I not dense like very
rich in other words it's not a bunch of
fluff I'm not turning a blog post into a
300 page book right like you you're
going to want can you tell us what it is
I can't I can't can you give me like a a
genre I can't really give you a genre
what I will it's not cooking book again
it's
not I got I think everybody got their
fill of of cooking with that I'm very
proud of that book but holy did
that almost kill me no I'm not doing
that again also not making the foolish
decision to say to myself you know what
I should do you know what be fun is for
me to do 30 to 50% of my own photography
for a 700 page cookbook don't do that
not archery if you're not a photographer
don't do that it is so much work oh my
God I I really respect to the
photographers out there underestimated
that one oh you dodg the archery
question it is an archery B it's not an
archery book I'm I'm planning on doing
more archery that is part of the
physical reboot okay but the the quick
creative collaborations this book is
going to be about I would say how to
find the essential and ignore the
trivial that's the very broad Strokes I
am collaborating on writing which I
thought I would never do it is going
better than I ever possibly could have
imagined and
it has opened the floodgates for me to
think about what other collaborations I
could pursue scream plays animation
television who knows but I've realized
that if I am paired with someone who
really gives a about quality and
cares about being really proud of their
work I'm totally fine I can collaborate
really well with those people they just
have to have really high standards and I
I'm excited to do more of that so the
the screenplay side and like the TV and
animation is particularly interesting to
me so becoming more Adept with a format
like a screenplay and the format itself
has intimidated me and I feel like I
just need to be locked in a room with
someone really good for two weeks and be
like you cannot leave until you have
something to ship it can be a rough
draft but it has to be pretty much ready
and I think that's doable so the quick
creative collaborations is is something
that I'll be doing more of and then last
on the physical reboot it's I have been
such a piglet in the
last month you're looking
thick that's a thicc folks looking thick
and I am I'm not in terrible shape but I
am planning on continuing to be a little
piggy for Christmas in the holidays
because I'm going to be home with family
and like I love I love butter cookies I
love gingerbread cookies I'm not this is
kind of like you not committing to your
three months before your birthday that
would be stupid yeah so I'm G to be
spending January February in really
intense outdoor training and skiing and
ski touring and so on so I'm not worried
about burning off what I'm accumulating
cuz that's going to happen especially at
high altitude I'm going to try and visit
you by the way awesome January that
would be fantastic so the physical
reboot is is up there and I'm optimistic
about that because on the internal level
meaning by biomarkers and so on almost
every biomarker is the best that it's
been in like a decade wow after the last
year that is not me that sounds amazing
yeah and some of that has been uh
certainly physical practice exercise a
lot of that has been dietary since how's
your apob the best it's ever been how
low I can't recall offand okay it's with
with 20 to 30s I mean it's within the
aggressive AA yeah target range St alt
fine oh yeah are always fun homosysteine
always good homosysteine is always fun
yeah my my liver enzy what been your
issues then what was that what what are
your issues what what did you correct in
your blood work there are a couple of
things that I've corrected so I have
historically high uric acid levels oh so
but you're on alopurinol then I'm not on
alopurinol because I had a reaction to
it which can be very dangerous so I'm on
something called uloric which is fine
and it's actually a better a cleaner
drug I think at is people can yeah there
there's a bunch of debate around it
because there were some smaller studies
that were were arguably poorly designed
that did some type of head-to-head and
and it it got poo pooed but uloric for
me is a good option not medical advice
talk to your doctor please I
don't play one on the internet in
addition to that that's from your meat
by the way you know that that's your
meat intake no it's not are you sure yes
I'm sure typically uric acid you know
they used to call it the uh the king's
disease right cuz it causes gout and it
was from like wine it's considered a
disease of a okay so the wine is more
interesting okay so yes people associate
it with if I'm not mistaken purines and
it gets Associated therefore with with
protein intake also but there's a
there's a blog post I it's easy to
forget I have a thousand plus blog posts
which actually bridged the books to the
podcast it's easy to forget that
connective tissue with a thousand plus
blog posts one of them is called
something like the hidden chapter from
good calories bad calories good calories
bad calories book great book uh Gary
garys GS and one of the chapters that
ended up on The Cutting Room floor was
about
fructose and how T is anti right which
also ties into uric acid yes so what I
have seen in myself at least it doesn't
matter if I am carnivore diet vegan
fasting whatever dietary lever I try to
pull uric acid is high it just does not
matter and that's also hereditary this
runs in in my family the other
constellation of issues are all cardiac
like lipid profile related also
hereditary dietary intervention with the
exception of one thing that I'll mention
are you on a Statin I'm not on a Statin
okay well you're able to be is fine just
to be clear so I there are different
reasons that your lipid profile can be
out of whack in my particular case and I
might be able to put something in the
show notes as a resource in there are
sophisticated
Labs or companies that will run Labs
that sort of f slice a lot of this
Boston Heart I think it's Boston Heart
yeah and then you need someone to
interpret the tea leaves obviously in
which case you need a very confident
doctor in my case I'm a cholesterol
hyper absorber more accurately I'm a
sterile hyper absorber which means I can
also absorb a lot of steriles from say
plant matter which is why
automatically if you reduce meat or
eliminate meat it doesn't mean that
you're cardiac and lipid profile will
improve and you actually see a lot of
folks for which it goes the opposite
direction because they end up consuming
a lot more refined carbohydrates they
their fast and glucose goes up and they
end up with a whole host of issues in
some cases associated with fructose
right like oh Agave Nector brilliant
well maybe not so brilliant and for that
reason in my case I'm taking a Zam
actually I'm taking something called NEX
lasette which is absurdly expensive
welcome to the United States in this
case but it's a combination of aetam and
something called bidic acid aetam very
well researched pretty well understood
bidic acid a newer a newer player on the
scene M but very interesting and the
combination of those two plus the uloric
are what got a number of biomarkers of
concern not crazy and I've done not only
the usual cardiac Cal scores which are
helpful but incomplete in a lot of ways
I've also done angiograms which you do
not want to do willy-nilly all the time
but I wanted to see if there were any
precursor to issues so far so good in my
particular case those things plus
reducing saturated fat
intake differ killer differ screws up
all my numbers it makes a difference so
in my case you know if it would be a bad
idea for me to hit the like MCT
smoothies right right so yes Bulletproof
Coffee bad idea for me also MCT I don't
know if it does it to you but it
disaster pants risk goes up yeah yeah
risk goes up by about 10x yeah if if
you're like run run to the bathroom with
the MCT oil yeah yeah if you if you are
thinking to yourself you know in 2024 I
want to Sho my pants more often I would
recommend constipated yeah yeah creatine
Double Espresso and MCT oil problem
solved don't ask me how I know that but
you can guess uh don't don't have that
right before you're driving to the
airport for your international flight
also Pro tip so the minimalist
delegation fast delegation re embracing
reversible or lowcost possible mistakes
yeah quick creative collaborations and
then physical reboot and honestly with
the physical reboot a lot of that is old
news the stuff that works works it's
like kettle bell swings Zone skiing yeah
zone two which I'll get to very
naturally with what I'm going to be
doing and in terms of hiking and ski
touring and so on basic basic basic like
the I shouldn't say Basics the
fundamentals are the fundamentals for a
reason and just when in doubt return to
fundamentals it's like weight training
wants a week that is better than nothing
once a week and then the zone two but
also for me it's like one or two
sessions of very very hard technical
Pilates to hit everything that I'm going
to miss anyway like medial glute and
trans by the way yeah and uh that's
about it do less than you think you can
do if if some of your goals are around
physical reboot or
recomposition set the bar where you are
sure you can clear it yeah right so I
want to talk to you real quick about you
know you you mentioned the physical body
reboot one of the things that all of my
Physicians bougie to say all my
Physicians my primary care physician
tell us President Obama has been has
been concerned about is I have slightly
elevated blood pressure and it's not to
the point where it's we I should have it
treated with medicine yeah but you know
there's breathing exercises you can do
there's a device called respirate which
Peter Tia recommends I don't know yeah
it's fantastic it hooks around um your
chest it's like a strap and then you put
in some ear pods that are connected to
this device and it walks you through a
series of breathing exercises and it's
clinically proven to lower your blood
pressure so Tia recommends that as kind
of first line defense for slightly
elevated blood pressure mhm there is a
device that is approved in the UK and
the EU and it's called ACA and it's a
horrible name
what ACA not AA they're going to get a
froma yeah so it's a AK K TI I a I'm
wearing it on my wrist right now okay so
if you're watching the video version you
can see this thing is smaller than the
smallest Fitbit it's super tiny the
battery life is 5 days it does every
hour blood pressure monitoring it's
clinically like proven accurate and AA
is testing it right now in his lab with
his folks there it is not approved in
the US so what I had to do is I bought
it online first I I got a VPN I proxied
into their website to make it look like
it was in the UK and then I bought
online shipped it to a friend in the UK
who sent it to me in the states I then
created a fake iCloud account in the UK
with a fake email address and VPN to
like I was in the UK on a separate phone
that I had not sent in like one of my
older iPhones and then I was able to get
the app installed through the UK app
store because it's not available in the
US app store and got it to work so
technically this is not legal in the
United States Contraband but it's uh you
know it's I'm I'm actually monitoring it
and the breathing exercises are helping
it high salt intake combined with water
is huge if you have a salty steak or
anything like I can noticed like just
like when we remember when we first got
into cgms you were way before I was but
into continuous glucose monitors you got
me into them and you you would be
surprised because you would sit there
and you'd be like oh banana doesn't do
anything and some people banana shoots
you through the roof right or rice for
me oh my God through the roof I don't
know about you but rice for me is a a
huge offender rice affects me less than
it affects you but it affects a lot of
folks yeah footnote and a previous
episode we talked about the rice cooker
the rice cooker which drains out the
water yeah which dramatically reduces
the glycemic response so but back to our
schedule program yeah we can link that
link that in the show notes as well but
this for me has been like okay I just
had a a salty meal now let me chug a
bunch of water along with that meal and
actually I will notice a difference I do
not get into those what they call like
the high orange levels of blood pressure
just by my water consumption so meaning
you you help or hurt meaning by drink
water by drinking more water yes
drinking water and there's evidence back
this up but he's had people on the
podcast have talked about this but
anyway it's it's another device that I
hope knock on with they submited to the
FDA hope is that we'll have this device
approved in the states here I don't know
next six months to a year so we'll see
very cool anything else on the physical
reboot side I mean the three months with
no booze I think is going to be if you
can do it no offense it'll be a
revelation I think it's going to be
amazing speaking of it you don't looks
like you're not a big fan of your own
tequila well I I just know you're not
really drinking any so well first of all
no I mean if you don't like it it's
you're just selling it that's fine it's
also we started recording at 3 p.m. so
usually I'm not a 3 p.m. drinker but you
know what I'm going to be in bed by 700
so
it you know oh Jesus okay so you know
since since we're going we're we're just
checking back into the home anyway where
they're going to put our socks on and
put us to bed no problem yeah yeah all
right dude let's retire at the same
retirement home that' be so fun so much
fun yeah well I'm
say say something cheers man see you
cheers and uh so let's talk
about I always enjoying taking breaks
from stuff because I have kind of a wild
story which I don't think we've talked
about at all I have a number of wild
stories oh yeah I got one big one for
today you have a big you have a big one
too and I think these are going to be
interrelated in a sense I'll piggyback
half of it after
what I believe you're going to share but
I took a month off of caffeine anything
caffeinated which was the first turkey
cold turkey which was the first time
I've done that probably I would have to
imagine since I was what 16 I mean it's
been forever let me ask you a question
here why would you do that cold turkey
why not just do like oh a half a cup of
coffee today and then maybe a quarter
cup a few days later like why go this is
like the extreme Tim did you get
headaches you must have got yeah I got
headaches but but it was during a period
where I could you had VI no I didn't use
vikin I I knew that I could accept the
headaches and I had a period of time
where there really was a low cost where
like professionally I was taking 3 to
four weeks off the grid and I knew that
I had a grace period where I could
sustain it so I did
effectively no caffeine no
alcohol and I suppose the most important
other item no sex no ejaculation which
is we can talk about that that's pretty
easy uh the the harder one is I did
nothing
sweet so not just containing sugar but
nothing sweet so anything that has an
artificial sweetener was out would you
consider this tequila sweet I would not
consider this tequila sweet and there is
a there is a bit of subjectivity for a
lot of it it's got sweet notes to it
like it's not yeah it's it's got some
floral notes to it but by the kind of
letter of the law I wouldn't consider
this subjectively to be sweet but for
instance any kind kind of juice out any
type of sweetener of course out let's
just say different types of plantains if
they are sweet to The Taste they're out
sweet potatoes out and is that hard for
you that that that's not hard for me it
doesn't seem hard but let's just extend
this almost every toothpaste has
sorbital or some kind of crap in it
right that is a sweetener so no brushing
your teeth for two weeks I brush my
teeth with sodium bicarb just baking
soda up I I brushed my teeth with that
for for a handful of of weeks and what
you also realize is in the US or in this
case when I went to Korea if you ask
people if if a or C has any added sugar
there is sugar or some type of sweetener
in almost everything yeah that you come
across that was interesting it was
challenging cuz it's severely limited
what I could
eat but the
caffeine was an amazing experience now I
alluded to this a little bit earlier I'm
back on the sauce over the last week
week and a half which I regret number
one and I'm paying a lot for like there
are costs I can explain I so let me let
me back up and I'll just give you the
the punch tell us why you did this to
begin with because you didn't mention
that like it wasn't a New Year's
resolution why yeah I so the reason I
did it started because I was in South
America doing a bunch of weird stuff and
there were restrictions and then I just
extended everything but weird stuff
let's let's psychedelics stuff yeah
psychedelics okay which which will tie
into a part of My Strange story
later but I hadn't done the type of
training I was doing in South America in
probably five or six years and so I took
restrictions very seriously I think that
is important in my opinion and then I
extended them all and I wanted to see in
part because I met someone one who said
they had stopped drinking anything
caffeinated cold turkey because they
felt like a loser because they they'd
become dependent on it and they missed a
really important ski day like one of the
first days of the season and they're a
really good skier and they were with a
group of people and they were the only I
believe they were the only person who
skipped and that day they were just like
no more and to this day you know like
two years later caffeine free and wa
wait I lost something there when I wake
up in the morning and I have a couple
coffee I can go skiing why did they miss
skiing cuz they couldn't have coffee
they were because they didn't have
coffee that morning and they were so
tired oh that they felt like they
couldn't do it so they stayed on the ski
lift instead of getting off they just
went around went straight back down
amazing and called it a day and and to
their credit under the weather or
something but to their credit they were
just like this is loser Behavior
enough and they went to zero that caught
my attention because when you talk to
someone no no offense to anyone who fits
in this category but let's just say if
someone is a Mormon and they've never
had
caffeine that's not my life right
they've never had a hit of the sauce I
mean although technically their
workarounds like Diet Coke instead of
coffee but well we're not going to get
into the weeds here but like if somebody
hasn't had a taste of the like delicious
poison there's so many things right
there's so many things like this where
it's like okay if you've had one
significant other and you've never been
out and about in like sampled the buffet
of the world like we can't really have
it's very hard to have an Apples to
Apples talk about relationships like
it's just it's a different situation
right same with caffeine but this person
had been hitting the sauce for decades
and then they got off and that was
inspiring to me then I had this
restriction and I just extended it and
just to give the
punchline my sleeping issues that I've
had for decades every single one just V
vanished best sleep of the last 20
years woke up Wide Awake every morning
after the first like let's just call
like week and a half had tons of
energy and
got super high volume of of stuff done
and what I realized and the part of the
reason to answer your meta question why
did I do all of these things I was
curious what my real Baseline was like
what does real Baseline look like what
is Tim untouched unaffected by all these
various supplements that's another thing
I took a month off of all supplements I
only I only took my prescription meds
like the uloric and so on yeah I got rid
of all
supplements and no Deca or testosterone
anything no de no nothing okay and I was
very curious to reacquaint myself with
what like the sort of pure Baseline Tim
is and
turns out Baseline Tim does really well
and why go back then why why well you
got hung over no I didn't get hung I
didn't get hung over it's good after
after hangover a little bit of L juice
so I also before I went to South America
I listened to an audio book which was
called or is called the easy way to quit
caffeine and that that is an extension
of a brand that started with smoking I
think it's the easy way to quit smoking
and I know people who have literally
multiple people who have listened to
this they have their last cigarette and
they're done and they stop so it's a
little hokey but that made an impact on
me as well I'll do that for January I'm
write that down on my list January no CA
and I'm now that I know I can do it I'm
definitely going to do it again the
reason that I got back on it and this is
this is I'll actually add just a little
bit of color the first is that there
were days without caffeine where I would
say to myself I'm tired I really want a
cappuccino but I realized because I
interrogated I was like well I'm not
allowed to have a cappuccino am I really
tired and I came to the conclusion that
no I wasn't actually tired I just wasn't
wired you see what I mean like
my my normal had become multiple coffees
in the morning and God knows what else
so I had taken as my
Baseline a default I mean wired sounds
too negative but like stimulated State
and when that was removed the story that
I conjured was I'm
tired but when I I was unable to have
the cappuccino and I went on to record a
podcast podcast turns out great I'm like
okay let me revisit this I wasn't tired
I was just calm interesting crazy
interesting and why did I get back on
coffee coffee for me I've realized is
probably like alcohol for a lot of folks
and there's sometimes I'm not gonna lie
look let's be honest here like there are
times when it's like I want to take the
edge off sure have a drink yeah right
but more often CU I don't drink that
much I use coffee as like a security
blanket when my life gets hit with
something unpredictable or
unpredicted and things seem a little out
of control or I'm not sure how I'm going
to make it through something like
walking to the coffee shop in the
morning and having that coffee it's it's
a life raft of consistency yeah we saw
this during Co right where people would
line up at Starbucks for 3 hours to get
a coffee because it was like the one
semblance of you know and there's also a
high to it so it's like there also a
high so even
though I realize intellectually that
it's counterproductive like when I am
feeling as I have been for a host of
reasons that I won't bore people with
but just gone through a a pretty
challenging week or two my response to
feeling a little anxious is to want
coffee even though it increases anxiety
now are you a coffee physiologically I I
this this is one thing actually we've
known each other for a long time I I
don't know the answer this I don't know
that have seen you do this are you an
afternoon coffee guy at all I don't know
that I've seen you do um mate maybe a
little bit later but like I I typically
do not have coffee in the afternoon yeah
and I really try not to have caffeine in
the afternoons which I violated this
week so in the last like two two days or
I should say in the last this just say
in the past seven days I have violated
that and what I've realized because I've
run the N of one now and there are a
bunch of different variables so I
realize this is imprecise it's not a
perfect science is that I can drink
coffee and fall asleep that's not the
problem but it disrupts my sleep
architecture qu sleep I wake up after 3
days very little time 3 days of drinking
caffeine I wake up and I have circles
under my eyes like dark circles are you
are you quantifying this in in the sense
of like are you wearing an Ora ring do
you have any other data where you're
looking at it I'm not currently
capturing the data with an aura ring but
I have in the past yeah I've seen what
it looks like so I know that's the case
I'm falling asleep my time in bed if
we're just looking at a clock is fine
but I'm waking up tired I hate that and
then what do you want you want another
hit of course you want more of thece
juice and there's a lot to be said for
it this is not to completely knock
coffee like I don't think for the rest
of my life I'm going to be caffeine free
but now I have a better
awareness of what my Baseline looks like
so I can return to that so let me tell
you something crazy uh this was before I
met Daria so I'm I'm trying to go back
in in in years now so probably let's
just call it 15 years ago I gave up
coffee for about 6 months 6 months yeah
that's legit well but I wasn't really
that addicted to it I was having like a
cup every other day or whatever and I I
went back and I remember I was living
Liv in San Francisco at the time and I
went to rual Coffee which is fantastic
coffee place great place and I I ordered
a tall like single origin coffee and I
drank the whole thing when you go 6
months without coffee and you have a
full cup of coffee you feel high as a
kite super I was like 10x what I feel
today with a cup of coffee yeah cuz your
body just like I mean it is a powerful
drug when you you gone without it for a
while super powerful do you have any
sense of how long it takes to like get
that back
like how long do do have you done any
research like to get what back that
initial like like Childhood High of like
that first cup of coffee how long do you
go without before you get back you like
I don't know I don't know I will say on
the opposite end which is what I thought
you were asking how long does it take to
develop tolerance and experience with
withdrawal symptoms it is so fast oh so
fast and one day if you go without
coffee Serious Coffee drinkers will be
headaches yeah well I would say for
furthermore if you stop drinking coffee
and I'm using coffee as a bit of scape
cope here like I love coffee but if you
if you go without caffeine and then you
get back on caffeine and you're on it
for 2 or 3 days and then you stop again
my personal experience is you are going
to feel withdrawal symptoms and that is
unlike most other drugs it is a powerful
powerful powerful drug right like it I'm
not recommending this but hypothetically
if you were to like smoke cigarettes for
a few days and then stop you're fine
yeah no problem you're not going to have
a headache the next day but with
caffeine it is an incredibly powerful
drug and I think that's in part because
it is often disrupting sleep
architecture that's my that's my vote at
least one question for you one of the
things that I have yet to try that I've
been really curious about is I know that
there are cultures I can't remember I'm
going to screw it up I don't know if
it's like a Inca or I can't remember
exactly which culture it is from Mexico
that did high
do chocolate almost like like a cacao
ceremony where they drink like this like
super purified cacao like insane amounts
of caffeine and they like reach these
kind of spiritual states have you ever
heard anything about that I haven't read
reports but I know that for instance I
want to say in some places in Mexico
certainly in Guatemala you have caca
ceremonies I don't know I don't I was
invited to one one time a caca ceremony
so I don't know how much
I don't know the historical record right
I I don't know how much of these things
were used 100 years ago a thousand years
ago there are there are many new
practices that have created The
Narrative of ageold use right for a
veneer of credibility when in fact
things were very different a thousand
years ago you have to imagine Kaka was
AA has been around for a while so in the
case of cacao my understanding is it
contains theob bromine which in of
itself is a fascinating word Theo broma
Theo like theology broma food food of
the Gods theob bromine which is
pharmacokinetically it is very meaning
just if you look at the graph of peak
and halflife and so on it's quite
different from caffeine is is my is that
the Vaso dilator of the plant what
causes cuz I know like kova for example
mhm are you familiar with that
supplement kovia yeah it's like a it's a
caca supplement from a large company I
believe yeah from from Mars actually
Mars but the crazy thing is is like I
was talking to Ronda Patrick about this
and she has had one of her I think it
was her mother-in-law or something like
that high blood pressure takes cavilla
drops it down because it's a VISA
violator and it's a big fan of it as
well and it's been showing cognitive
improvements as well yeah I'm not sure
it very well could be the case uh I mean
when you get the dose makes the poison
the dose also makes the Transcendence
for a lot of different plants and so in
the case of cacao I have experienced
higher let's call it higher dose cacao
and you can reach an alter state for
sure MH I'm going to cave out what I'm
about to say with the do not ever do
this warning but there for instance
there are plants that at high enough
doses are absolutely psychedelic which I
would never recommend because you can
die let me repeat that fatal risk so do
not do not try this at home but tobacco
as an instance as an example has a very
Rich history in South America and
elsewhere but especially in South
America where high doses of juice have
been consumed you have
like every mode of administration you
can imagine is has been done and is very
common down there there's a book by
Johannes Wilbert which
is titled along the lines
of tobacco and South American or tobacco
in South American shop omin ISM it is
very dense it reads like a PhD
dissertation but when you consume pretty
much through any route imaginable enough
tobacco you can experience a psych
experience God can I tell you a story
about this I've had this so I was in San
Francisco at the time and they have this
was call it a decade ago they have a
bunch of you know chefs that are very
experimental I won't name the chef but
it was one Michelin star Chef that tried
that that infused tobacco leaves into an
alcohol oh boy and you have to be
insanely careful if you look up online
you like you said if you put too many
leaves in the infusion you will have a
lethal overdose of you know nicotine
that will kill you yeah and so dis Chef
knew what they they were doing I would
never try this at home they made me a
bourbon
infused tobacco cocktail and I was like
sounds interesting I'll give it a shot
hope you don't need to sleep anytime
soon no listen I no I Dr I drank this
one drink and I'm like having a good
time getting a little chatty you know
like this is fun and then dude I get up
to use the bathroom boy and I swear to
God it felt like my feet were sinking
into the ground as I was walking where
like I was walking down like to the
stumps of my knees like I was like my
legs were like collapsing as I was
walking you're like wait a minute I was
like cuz I don't smoke um tobacco at all
or anything like that and it like hit me
like a ton of bricks and I'm like I am
high as like it is a very potent
substance like you especially for
nonsmokers you got to be really careful
so come in Full Circle right so caca
powerful fascinating plant sacred in in
a number of different
cultures tobacco be very careful folks
it is powerful and potentially lethal
and then coming back to caffeine it is
the as I understand it the world's most
commonly consumed psychoactive plant
right is is number one tea and coffee
yeah and it has this place I love my cup
of coffee trust me I had one this
morning and I think the exercise if you
can do it not everyone can but of
rediscovering what your Baseline is like
what you actually felt like when you
were 12 or 15 is writing this down so
valuable it is so valuable because I now
know what that feels like and I know
that I can return to it as an adult yes
that it holds true to any that you're
doing that you know call it alcohol any
substance that you've become dependent
upon yeah right it doesn't have to be
just caffeine it can be anything that
you've like that you almost feel like
you can't live without right sugar carbs
some activity traveling late night pizza
yeah late night pizza I mean like if if
you're a road warrior and you just
travel all the time cuz you say yes to
everything like okay what does it feel
like to sit at home
if such a thing exists for you for one
month what does that feel like and if a
bunch of weird stuff comes up like maybe
as Tara Brock would say like the you
know to the to to one Sage only one
question matters what are you unwilling
to feel oh my God I have to have her on
the podcast that is one of my top guests
I yeah so if you haven't read it folks
radical acceptance which I owe darar
thanks for so if you don't get D is my
wife
Daria we call him Tim Tim so which came
about actually let's give people a real
look into the archives so Tim Tim came
about cuz we were on a trip to China to
drink puera tea all over the place which
was one of the weirder trips I've ever
been on for a lot of reasons we were in
the UN Province together in the middle
of nowhere we had we had some very
strange experiences on that trip drank a
lot of tea had a motly crew of people
with us along for that ride and there
was another Tim on the trip so the there
was a question of how do we keep the two
of you separate and you came up with I
believe timtim I mean it was a uh
collaborative that's how Tim Tim came
about so Daria who is neuroscientist by
training yeah which is why I actually
took the book radical acceptance
seriously because at all due respect I
love Tara love this book it had a huge
impact on me but the title gave me an
allergic reaction I was like oh God
another one of these like I just I just
sounds handwavy okay Kumbaya Didu like
okay I just can't do it but the fact
that Daria who has one of the one of the
lowest tolerances for handwavy
stuff that I know of the fact that she
said she gained from it gave me
permission to dive into it which then
had a really big impact on me so coming
back though if you feel like you are you
can't live without X that is often a
great signal or at least a prompt to ask
yourself what might an experiment look
like for two to four weeks to go without
X been super valuable for me that's
awesome I'm I wrote it down no no
caffine in January I'm going I'm serious
you know I might I might Double Down do
it with you let's do it yeah yeah no
calf all right let's talk about my
experiments shall we yeah let's do it
I'm excited I'm excited about this cuz I
also don't know the details I know that
you saw the text messages saw some of
the text messages and I was very curious
okay so this is a big one um you're
pregnant I'm
pregnant what was the one where Arnold
swarzenegger got pregnant what was
it can't remember the name but yes I
know the movie basically that's I have
the same physique too um so basically
you know for for people that that that
know me or don't quite know me like you
know I've I've I've done a bunch of
stuff in terms of being like an
entrepreneur and an investor and these
different things and one of the the hats
that I put on you know a couple years
ago was dabbling in the world of web 3
and web 3 for those untrained you know
it's cryptocurrency it's it is
decentralized internet it is nfts it's
art on the blockchain ownership right if
if 1.0 is readon internet 2.0 is read WR
three is actually owning a piece of
what's on the plan so it's a very
exciting Frontier and it and it's filled
with a bunch of explorers that I would
say are it's a small number of people in
terms of people that are excited about
digital art call it you know 250,000
people or less but it is you know a
serious group of people that are
enabling a new canvas to take form in
front of us and I believe in my heart of
hearts that for all the bad press that
we see about nfts and all the scams and
don't get me wrong there's tons of that
there is something true about uh if
you had to close your eyes and wake up
in 20 years will collectible digital art
be a thing of course it will right like
and the blockchain is a perfect a
perfect place to like prove provenance
to prove scarcity there's a lot of
advantages there long story short you
know I
launched something called Moon Birds
which was a pfp project I remember the
text I got on the day of that launch oh
my God yeah so we launched this you know
collectible nft and it skyrocketed Way
Beyond what we had ever thought so to
give you all a sense from launch to one
year in over a milon dollar has been
traded in moonbird nfts that's so wild
um and I did not expect that you know I
really didn't but with that comes
trading and I have never lived the world
of trading I've grown companies to quite
some size but never publicly I've never
taken a a company public and when you
take a company public I.E NASDAQ you
know New York Stock Exchange you deal
with the ups and downs and feedback from
people that are now Stak holders of that
particular company it's different this
isn't Equity holding nft does not make
you a shareholder it's very different
but they still pay attention to what is
the price of this nft y so when the nft
goes up times are good people are happy
and when it goes down people are not
happy I've had people truly hug me and
say they've paid off their house because
they sold one of my nfts for $200,000
and they were stoked and it was like
tears kind of hugging I've had people
basically Tear Me Apart saying I am the
other person on the other side of that
equation that bought that nft for let's
Call it Whatever 50,000 75,000 10,000
doesn't really matter it's all relative
to how much that person has as an
individual and how are you going to fix
this because nfts are down and they need
to go up right right and some of it is
on you know what we we build to try and
build bigger and better things for the
ecosystem and try and hopefully prove
that we are a company here for the long
term it has taken an serious emotional
toll on me as an individual MH I've had
many many sleepless nights I've had
anxiety like I've never had before I've
had to work with therapists and I've had
to I've had to reach out to my primary
care physician and get anti-anxiety
medicine which I've never had to do
before I have had some dark moments with
some some not dark like in suicide but
dark as in you know it's destroyed me
because I've always considered myself an
honest person I've never been here to
screw anyone over you're also a very uh
I consider you to be an empathic feeler
maybe the right word is like you're a
deep feeler I am a feeler for sure for
sure if something like if something like
that is sitting with you you take it
very personally I remember when you had
like stomach issues
oh my God IBS related issues and that so
this year I've been you know treated
multiple times for you know these types
of issues with Physicians all kinds of
things they discovered you know the high
blood pressure thing was discovered
because I have a a brain aneurysm right
now that it's on the smaller side and
they're watching it and I'm fine but
those grow The more stress you're under
because the more blood pressure that
builds up the larger aneurism can grow
and so you know as you can imagine all
these things hit you at once yeah and so
I I felt overwhelmed I felt like I
couldn't go to work I felt like I I kind
of just needed to reset you know and
huberman who I love who's been on my
podcast Andrew hubman is a top 10
podcast now oh my God killing it killing
it love that guy he's doing such a an
amazing job of executing I don't think
I've seen anyone better at doing
monologues and and the way that he can
do them about scientific topics I mean
just if you haven't subscribed to humman
podcast I mean it's along with theas you
know top five medical podcasts to
subscribe to along with Ronda Patrick I
mean they're they're all heroes hberman
did a a couple Hour episode on ketamine
therapy MH and ketamine
therapy you know it's used for PTSD it's
used for severe depression and it's used
for anxiety and it sounded really
interesting it rewires neurop Pathways
and huberman's episode highly recommend
I'm not a scientist but he is and he
goes in depth about what it actually is
doing on the
brain and I always thought of ketamine
clinics as being these Shady places
these places where you know there are
real people with real addictions that
they treat you know if you're hooked on
everything from amphetamines to you know
any type of serious addiction problems
they see these types of people and also
people that are about to kill themselves
like really suicidal like if you go to
an emergency room right now and you say
I'm going to end my life in the next 10
minutes they will most likely treat you
with some type of ketamine to just like
get you out of that state it's a very
common emergency room Hail Mary to like
get you back into a state of like just
being okay I don't want to in my life
right now and now we can work this out
or or take you to an institution where
you can get help MH so I was never there
but I got to the point where I was like
I need to do something dramatic and
different and I need to reboot because I
can't take the comments I'm getting on
Twitter now did you see the huin episode
organically did someone send it to you
organically just came across it just
came across it I was like oh I've always
been interested in C I'd heard about
Kine in in a recreational setting and
you know sadly who is the friend Perry
yeah Matthew Perry Just toxicology
report came back and said that he was on
cemy when he drowned uh and but there's
we can get into why that that is in a
minute but in a yeah let's focus on your
personal experience and I'll just say
also ketamine and Jacuzzi or pools or
water do not mix ex there are multiple
fatalities don't mix those two things
well when you go into Academy and you
are literally sedating yourself to where
they can give you surgery dissociative
anesthetic so what what my doctor has
told me that the ceman doctor she's an
emergency room doctor that that did my
treatments is she said to me that if you
came she was a 10 year I think 10 or 15
years emergency room doctor and she goes
if you came in and you had like
dislocated your hip she goes I would
inject I would give you what they call a
Bolis dose is that what they call when
they a Bolis is right I mean they're
giving you a lot at once a lot at once
they just like push it all in right and
she's like I would give you that to
about like you know I can't remember the
exact X but it was a multiple on what
they give you for therapy to put you
under
so I can get that hip back into place
and then you wake up feeling fine
unfortunately with with Matthew Perry he
took a dose that was equivalent of
subconscious fainting falling asleep you
know drowning type dose and they said
the toxology report I read it he had
that level in him that would have put
him in that state of of of kind of like
passing out right yeah drugs and water
don't mix folks don't mix anyway wasn't
my point it wasn't the fault of the C I
mean it was he was using it
recreationally versus Under the
supervision of a professional which is
which is what is needs so I found this
this clinic in in La they literally have
the set and setting right so they're all
about like you come in it's just
beautiful comfortable peaceful music
really relaxing reclining chairs I mask
because it's important to go inward it's
not about just getting this therapy and
looking around the room music with like
drums and beautiful like sometimes I I I
picked my own playlist I did a little
bit more like chanting non non you don't
want like lyrics or you know anything to
distract you and they have you hooked up
to a blood pressure cuff that measures
throughout the time uh a heart rate
monitor like really professional setting
it's called Golden afternoon is the name
of the clinic in La amazing name it's an
amazing name and the doctor there top
tier you know School emergency room
doctor is legit as they come mhm I so I
felt really comfortable cuz you know a
lot of this is about set and setting and
comfort yeah and safety and safety yeah
so I went in there and they I was like
I'm going to give this a shot because
you know huberman convinced me that that
this can help me with anxiety and so you
know I I laid down in this comfortable
chair turn on the heating like they have
a heating element in the chair tilt you
back a little bit you know put on my
noise cancelling headphones they gave me
an IV and IVs does sound hardcore but
for for people like you and me that do
IVs like or do like blood draws like
every other weak who cares like I don't
care about this but it does sound
how C to most people M they gave me an
IV and you know I closed my eyes and I
went to a place man I went to a place
and it's a beautiful place and it made
me over multiple treatments and I did
eight in total and they normally do six
for depression which is really
interesting because she said that it's
typically anxiety is harder to to treat
than depression in her experience mhm
and they gave me eight in total and you
two two per week and about halfway
through the best way I can describe it
is imagine that life is a series of
crunches and I say crunches like the ab
workout okay whereas like nobody likes
to work out their abs right like and cuz
abs are like ah AB day like you
know nobody wants to do that and I
didn't realize it but I had had a 35 lb
weight on my chest the entire time I was
doing ab workouts and it took that
weight off and I had and I still have
and it's been Weeks Later a bit of Grace
and lightness to the way I'm carrying
myself throughout life that is just a
piece that I haven't felt since I was
probably 10 or 12 years old were you
interacting with anyone in those
sessions or was it all internal no it's
all internal so it's headphones on music
eye mask the entire session lasts for
about an hour and a half they have a
camera that's watching you if if
anything comes up one time I had my
music accidentally stop and I raise my
hand they're in there within 30 seconds
they bring you hot tea when you're done
they let you take your time to slowly
kind of like come to and then you can
literally walk out of there and carry on
with your day MH and it you know the
first session I was like okay that's
beautiful second session was a little
difficult imagine it's kind of loosening
up like like the plaque in your brain
and like rewiring circuits and like it's
not always going to be easy but by the
by I remember the six session I just
walked out there and and she Dr Jen came
in and she goes how are you and I said I
could run a marathon right now I feel
amazing I feel like a a weight has been
lifted off my chest and I just this is
such important work that you do such
important work because it's not about
being I don't feel there's not an
addiction to the substance I don't need
to go back some people go back for
boosters depending on what they have
they have she told me that some people
that have depression they'll come back
in you know every 3 months every 6
months she say some people she never
sees again mhm and it kind of takes the
anxiety and and puts it pulls it apart
from your body so that you can see it
for what it is which is silliness
because life is play and and when you
realize life is play and we're all here
just trying to figure out our yeah
why are we taking it so seriously yeah
there's a lot that just does not matter
it doesn't matter we can just chill man
it doesn't really matter so that we have
clean drinking water like what the
are we complaining about so the the
weight on the chest was that
something that you can't put words to
that you just felt release or and you
don't need to get into details but I'm
just curious or was there content to it
where you're like oh interesting wasn't
content content was beautiful I and and
I don't know if you've ever experienced
this Tim with I I've never done iasa
although at some point I would love to
try it but like I opened my eyes and it
was when the mask on and I was seeing
things that were as high of fidelity as
what we see today like right now Y where
you're like I am in a room right now and
I felt very present my dad's passed away
I felt very present with a father Source
there at times I felt very connected I
at one point I saw the entire world and
I saw how small I was and I was just
like it it g immediately gave me this
sense of just like gratitude for that
being that little speck but also at the
same time not having to take and carry
the burdens of the world on me for being
that little speck and so there's bits
and pieces of that but I would say at
the end of the day when you come out of
it it's not like you had this Epiphany
it's more like Dr Jen calls it
the ketam means time on she calls it
time time on brain how can we make this
sit and do the rewiring on your brain
and give you time on brain with the drug
and the compound and let it do its work
and so it was a lot of surrendering it
was a lot of saying you do what you want
to do I don't care where you take me
emotionally mentally whatever it doesn't
really matter it's time on brain with
the compound and after a certain number
of sessions you just feel this natural
lift and lightness and it it felt like
I I'm not a ballerina big surprise but
it felt like uh it felt like a little
bit of a like walking through life is a
little bit of a dance now than it is
such a
struggle it makes me super happy man to
hear that and it feels amazing and I
remember getting the the text some of
the texts from you and I was excited to
have this conversation which we haven't
had this is the first time we're talking
about it it is and I I'll say a few
things the first is that I have seen a
number of cases where k mean therapy has
changed or saved lives so a friend of
mine for instance who suffered from
depression his entire adult life had a
similar experience to yours and he went
to a clinic I believe it was in New York
City very well-run and he goes back once
every 6 months for a single tuneup let's
just Sayer session yeah and I actually
know also not going to mention their
name but some someone we know as a
mutual friend who you probably don't
know also does this once every 3 to 6
months and separately I know someone
who's in law enforcement who is heavily
disincentivized from talking about
mental health with his superiors because
you will be put on leave generally if
you even hinted that and you're in
certain professions airline pilot for
instance MH you're going to be put on
leave and it's a on leave is a a nice
way to say you probably nice way it's a
it's a it's a career risk to bring these
things up yeah which puts many more
people at risk right there there should
be better processes for this but
nonetheless he was suicidal at one point
we're talking about somebody who was
carrying around a firearm all day and
ketamine was an intervention that
yeah was incredibly effective for him
for pattern interrupting and I use that
very literally because the pattern was a
thought Loop this is personal this is
permanent this is never going to change
and when you're able to at least
interrupt that for a short period of
time you provide people with hope or at
least a window within which they can
consider other options MH so for acute
suicide suicidal ideation uh also for
chronic pain very interestingly ketamine
is super interesting it's interesting
you say that because she Dr Jen over
this Clinic has told me she treated
quite a few people for chronic pain as
well and it works quite well so I
unexpectedly because have you done it so
before I talk to anyone about anything
like this generally I am volunteering to
be the monkey shot into space so several
years ago I did six sessions over three
weeks Kine yeah oh dude why did you
never tell me this I didn't realize I
didn't tell you so I did six sessions
this would have been with the mask on
and like in the music in this particular
case it was music but it was not mask on
the way that this particular Clinic ran
things was with video which was very
strange to me but nonetheless it was
sort of nature Scapes and I was like
okay well this is new to me I'll try it
and it ended up being supremely
interesting I was not going in with an
acute condition so it was hard for me to
evaluate ultimately yeah a lot of the
efficacy they found it very strange and
I found it kind of hilarious because
they would do an intake each day of of
active sessions they and they would ask
me to do various assessments for anxiety
and my anxiety levels were going up over
time which they found very confusing
because you may have experienced a
little bit of this ketaman can
compromise your short-term memory in the
short term like after session so you
might like forget where your wallet is
or forget where your backpack is okay so
that can happen and that happened to me
and it happened to be the case that
while I was doing these sessions because
I shoehorned it into my schedule I also
had a number of huge podcasts coming up
like LeBron James and so on and it was
freaking me out that I kept forgetting
and so my anxiety was going up over
the course of treatment which was not
typically so I did the same thing they
gave me a whole like breakdown it was
one to five on you know a bunch of
different scales I think it's a pretty
standardized like you know thing that
they give you I can't remember what the
anxiety scales are but like mine went
down to literally a one on all of them
or zero on all of them which is amazing
it is amazing and I I want to mention a
few other things so I'm sure hu's
episode is is excellent for people who
want to have a comprehensive overview of
ketaman I'm sure H is great so listen to
that first it's fantastic I also did an
episode with John Crystal who Dr John
Crystal who is the chairman of
Psychiatry at Yale who did a lot of the
seminal
research with respect to ketamine as an
anti-depressant in humans so the
protocols that get used which I think
are generally like .5 Mig per kilogram
of body weight Etc over X period of time
with Y number of infusions those are the
protocols that he developed with his
other uh
investigators and I want to mention a
number of things just to to make sure
that I'm doing my my safety first ferris
Duty so the first is that part of the
reason and this is pure speculation but
I think that it was risky
for Matthew Perry to use ketamine is
that he had a history of abuse ketamine
can be very addictive for people who are
unwilling or uneager to feel certain
things a dissociative anesthetics so if
you have for instance a history of
alcohol abuse it is I would say
increasingly likely that that you might
abuse ketamine which is why if someone
were to consider ketamine therapy I feel
very strongly that it should be IV or
yes intramuscular injection
and not at home treatment where you have
access to say loes or nasal spray cuz
there are companies that do loes at home
but I will say one thing Tim real quick
and I'll let you continue I noticed my
desire for alcohol go down y so there
are this I think that that can happen
and I'm just saying for folks who for
instance may be coming out of or part of
AA and they have issues with
depression my personal take after
everything I've seen is that uh prior
abuse of alcohol highly correlated to uh
potential abuse of ketamine and uh I
would say furthermore there are some
Urological risks if you use ketamine
chronically and alongside
that if you use ketamine chronically and
this is true for a lot of drugs actually
not that's for snorting though right no
it's not for SN I mean snorting you
would your logical TR otherwise cuz it
metabolizing the liver well most people
who consume ketamine recreationally well
do be their mouth or it'll be a lot of
it'll be snorting of one way of one sort
or another so they'll either have it in
it'll be in suspension and a liquid or
it will be a powder they snort in the
same way they would snort cocaine a lot
of people carry little lockets around
their necks with ketamine I've seen this
a lot and by the way that's not what I'm
talking about here today I'm not those
but those are two very different things
they are so just to be very clear
ketamine therapy with IV or IM has a
track record of being
incredibly promising for a train
physician for a number of other things
but where where some folks get lost is
they go
from they go from instead of clinical
setting higher dose supervised they
bleed into more casual recreational use
in in which case it's very important for
me to say that ketamine can be very
helpful for people with say treatment
resistant depression or chronic
depression if you use it chronically
though it flips the other way and it
actually makes you predisposed to more
depression so it's just something for
people to be aware of yeah and as is
true with so many things more is not
better what was the drug that Michael
Jackson died of do you remember the name
of that I'm not sure I think it was a
synthetic opioid or no no no no it was
basically
some type of anesthetic yeah it was
funny I went and you know cuz I'm old
now in my 40s I went and have my first
col osoby because like you're supposed
to do that you know Party Time have
you done that yet or no I have yes yes I
went and did mine and um and by the way
this is this is very sad but do not skip
your colonoscopies no a very
good friend of mine since we last spoke
Roland Griffith who's an amazing
scientist from John's Hopkins he died of
terminal cancer and uh I had a long
conversation with him a few days before
he died before I went to South America
he was completely raiser sharp up until
the end and my recollection is that part
of the reason that was caught too late
is that he was a few years late in
having his exam yeah so I had mine done
and they caught uh a couple precancerous
as they do with most people these days
yeah do your screens and you got
to do your screens but anyway long story
short when I was going in the
anesthesiologist came in the room and he
was kind of a funny guy it was cool I
like those guys you know yeah and I and
I I asked him I said can I have this
slow ramp and he's like what's the slow
ramp I'm like well you just kind of get
to me a little bit at time just I just
like feel like going into that like that
zone you know and he's like that's funny
you say that he's like I'm giving you
the same drug they gave Michael Jackson
when he died and I was like oh that's
crazy I'm like why and he's like he was
just addicted to it and so he gave me
the slow ramp and I remember this
feeling about probably let's call it 30
seconds into it where I felt like I was
okay with dying it was just like this
moment of like this is beautiful yeah
and I was like oh my God this is what
Michael Jackson was feeling right now
prop prop fall yeah exactly that was it
and so I get it but it's but this is
like to the point of of Matthew Perry
dying in the in the pool like this stuff
puts you under it puts you under so that
you can have
surgery and that that is what ketamine
does as well so and ketamine broadly
speaking is an incredibly well tolerated
safe drug part of the reason that
ketamine is I believe listed in the
world Health organization's top 100 most
essential medicin is because it is
generally very well tolerated yes and it
does not suppress respiration yes
exactly which is a huge one right
gigantic and it's an incredible compound
and you just need to know the risk
profile and there are risk profiles for
everything of course you know we have
tequila and we have water in front of us
water has a risk profile too people die
every year of hypon nuta because they
drink too much water when they're
training for or running in a marathon
and that causes disruption of sort of
electrochemical signaling and then boom
they drop and people die every year you
probably didn't hear about this but
there was a a a radio host DJ you
remember this you know what I'm talking
about where they have these water
drinking I some overdosing on water this
has happened many times
right as paracelis would say the dose
makes the poison but sometimes the
frequency in the use pattern makes the
poison yeah and I think ketamine is
incredibly interesting and especially
cuz the the the when you get into the
actual science behind it we're not just
using this as an escape it's actually
rewiring the brain and and hubman will
get into that the the the kind of
Neurology behind it and what's happening
and why are these are more lasting
changes and why some people not everyone
but some people can go and do this and
they don't ever have to go back for a
booster or anything else and it changes
them forever so I don't know if I should
get into this someone someone we can
always cut it well someone very close to
me she was close to suicide and she's
she's a dear friend she's a sweetheart
of a person and she was the first time
i' had ever heard a camian therapy this
was probably four years ago and she said
I was about to take take you know the
closest take in her life and she had
heard about Academy and therapy it was
like kind of new at the time and she
paid for the six-pack the six sessions
you know the the the full six and and
she hated every single session and it
was funny when I talked to Dr Jen at at
the clinic that I went to she said it's
very common people that have depression
they don't enjoy the experience and I
thought it was fantastic I Lov the whole
thing but but like when my my friend
said that at sess session six she heard
a pop in her brain like a physical pop
it's like a psychic Chiropractic
adjustment dud literally the depression
lifted and she has been amazing ever
since so wild and this has been like 5
years ago yeah and it's like I I believe
her she's like doing insanely well now
yeah and it's like oh my God like dude I
I so Tim I just want to like one thank
you for how much money and effort you've
put into psychedelic research because
thanks man I After experiencing this I I
realized that there is something here
yeah and we don't have it figured out
yeah obviously we don't like we're in
the baby stages but you know 10 20 30
years with AI maybe 10 years like this
will get figured out and it will be
largely because people like you help
fund this type of research so I just
want to say thank you for that thank for
saying that brother yeah I really
appreciate that and I was so happy to
see this this text yeah I was so happy I
I got to tell you if you're in the if
you're in the LA area and obviously
you'll talk to her as a doctor this is
her advice not ours and you'll you'll go
through the whole screening process but
golden afternoon uh. Clinic I think is
the website and she is an amazing human
very caring comes in pre- and post
checks in on you like a really well-run
facility it you know depression anxiety
PTSD War veterans all these people are
going in to see her it's God's work if
wherever you believe in God or not yeah
there are some there are some great
clinics out there I will say there are
also a lot of fly by night clinics 100%
so do your homework yes the the one of
the main advantages or it is a main
advantage of ketamine as compared to
other psychedelics is that in the United
States it is currently legal yes and
that is a non-trivial advantage and I
will say that one question you may want
to ask in doing your due diligence if
you consider this is an option and I do
feel after canvasing many different
compounds many different treatments that
for for acute suicidal ideation that
ketamine is at the very top of the list
it is on a very short list of
interventions that have incredible
promise for at least creating the space
for someone to consider treatment
options and the question the due
diligence question that I recommend and
this is true for any type of drug
assisted therapy it's actually true for
surgeons too it's true for doctors in
general ask them what types of Adverse
Events they've observed what type of
abuse potential they've observed if
their answer is everything is always
fine we've never had an adverse event
yeah that is a huge red flag yes anyone
who has enough mileage if they are
ketamine Clinic physician if they are an
ER physician they will be able to tell
you what things look like when things go
sideways yes and how they handle those
situations and if they don't volunteer
any of that it means either they're
inexperienced or they're delusional
generally 100% And I'm giving people a
bit of a break or it means they're lying
and in all three cases you do not want
to have anything to do with that
particular practitioner by the way I I
looked her up she's a Princeton
Princeton yep go Tigers look at
that that's where my do my
doctor Phil wolson for in has has done a
lot of writing on this do your homework
you you're you are signing up for let's
just call it psychoactive brain surgery
so to the extent that you would do your
due diligence related to a surgeon who
is going to be physically opening your
head carving a hole in your skull and
Performing manual brain surgery do a
commensurate amount of homework on the
person who is going to be providing you
with compounds that have a a significant
impact on cognitive functioning
functioning not necessarily only in the
short term but in the longer term yeah
you want to hear another crazy drug
story let's hear it that's why we're
here yeah all right I'll give you a
refill speaking of drugs Andrew huberman
would would not be
pleased disapprove although likes
Straight Tequila yeah occasionally a TIA
will have a drink or two and he just
knows what he's signing up for anyway we
we can come back to this part of the
reason that you know I had a wild
experience in Portugal recently no
matter how much wine I have there I do
not have a headache the next day it's
and and I think it's additive related I
I can feel tired it'll up my sleep
I mean at the end of the day it is it is
alcohol but fascinating how different my
physiological response yeah can be in
any case that's true with this stuff too
for me personally with lava that's great
to hear considering I'm consuming a good
portion of it yeah a good portion all
right so let's I got to talk to you
about my tattoo at some
point okay should we all right you know
what I'm going to leave that as a
cliffhanger we're going to come back to
Wild drug story that's why I'm here in
town oh I didn't know that oh yeah
you're going to hear about the the crazy
machine what okay let's tattoo and crazy
machine what's going on one of the the
the premier generative artists by when I
say generative what I mean by that for
those that don't know is like there's a
whole genre of uh art that is code based
that that you know you write actually
computer science code like and and you
create art and one of the the the
premier artists in the space that's been
sold at chrisy and sou bees and all over
the place is Tyler Hobbs he's based here
such an awesome guy too another
sweetheart guy by the way he told me uh
he's always enjoyed hanging out with you
he's hang out with you a couple times
what a nice guy he's he he and his wife
are just lovely beyond words such great
people yeah and so Tyler lives here in
Austin and you know his nfts you can say
what you want of nfts but his nfts are
just absolutely gorgeous pieces of Art
work and and can sell for at times
millions of dollars like they're they're
really sought after also a legit visual
artist outside of Coach oh my God like I
went to the studio today and he pulled
open binders that he's been doing for
like Decades of his visual art and it's
just like he's not in this for the quote
unquote nfts like he's an artist like to
his core he strikes me as the person
that's always saying what's next how can
I push things in a different direction
right and there's a company based out
here called black dot does the has a
machine it's a robot that uses not
tattoo needles but you know when like
people get like their eyebrows like
cosmetically tattooed on I can imagine
it it's a common thing like some some I
don't want to be gender based here but
it's mostly women they get it like
tattooed on as their eyebrows but like
they use a much finer needle than they
would say a tattoo gun okay and so this
robot this
machine uses these really fine needles
and what they do is they take and we can
put this in the video as well they put
this kind of template on your arm that
is more or less just like almost like a
a QR a massive QR code kind of like grid
on your arm so that's my forearm I was
wondering about that you sent me a text
and I was like what the hell I like is
that another is that your tattoo okay no
it's just like a giant QR code yeah like
a giant QR code across my forearm and
that allows the the the optical lenses
and the lasers and everything to to
align the tattoo it is doing
177,000 small micro like pushes into my
skin with this needle okay and it does
it they can gauge with like these depth
sensors like the correct depth of the
dermis to go in so that the ink doesn't
spread out and fade over time so they
can do insanely High Fidelity tattoos
like stuff you've never like picture
perfect like even when you see those
pictures of like oh that person got that
baby tattooed on their like chest how
cute like imagine 10x the Fidelity of
that where you'd be like somebody took a
picture and like pasted it on their
chest yeah they have a machine that can
do that so you're never getting those
off if you change your mind what this is
is Tyler started with he drew me a
sparrow and the reason I like a sparrow
is because to me a sparrow is the most
common low ego bird to me that's out
there it just reminds me that in like
like I'm just getting a little sensitive
but like reminds me that we are all just
sparrows we don't need to take each
other like no one's better than anyone
else we we're all a common bird we're
all humans right and then what he did is
he applied an algorithm to it that
degrades the bird into a pixelated form
over three images oh that's cool yeah
and so the last one is his last
algorithm of the more pixelated version
and so you can imagine I'm getting this
tattooed on my arm tomorrow and and so
wait you're getting a tattooed tomorrow
what is that this is just a stencil oh
so I want I want to show you this today
of what thec look like so you can
imagine a world where literally in the
future how long does that stencil last
you you could wipe it off and and with
some alcohol and stuff but it's like you
know just there for the show of the show
but you can imagine a world where he can
give you an algorithm like he does with
his artwork and you can walk in put your
arm underneath this machine and get a
unique generative piece by an artist
that is one of one unique to you as
defined by an insanely famous artist
imagine if Picasso had the tools in his
day to say I'm going to create an
algorithm that is a bunch of crazy
Swirls and Chaos that is my brain yeah
or a bank or whoever bank or whoever and
you stick your arm in and you get a
oneon-one
Picasso like it's it's they're only
doing three of them this is a brand new
machine and brand new technology and so
that's why I'm out here to do a
oneon-one Tyler Hobs on my arm with a
sparrow so that's tomorrow black dot
black dot yeah it's it's a new kind of
startup out here a man there's a lot
happening here there's a lot happening
that's cool it's so cool yeah I want to
show you the one they did of the Mona
Lisa it's amazing stuff you don't have
do you have any tattoos at all you don't
do you no I've been thinking about
getting my first which is why I asked
about the stencil so look at that oh
yeah it's like just the eyes of the Mona
Lisa right there like but look how look
how high fidelity that is
yeah that's wild yeah that's that's
pretty wild so you've been thinking
about getting one I've been thinking
about getting one for years which would
be Molly Molly's paw prints on my
forearm you but not what was that you
would not are you serious yeah that' be
kind of awesome how ises Molly now
Molly's eight between eight and nine the
toaster is slowing down man yeah it's
it's so sad there's nothing more
heartbreaking than starting to see your
dog start to go on the decline yeah like
he's fall he's falling now like his legs
are falling I
know we don't have to take the podcast
there but yeah know it's bad no but it's
like hey toter's been with the podcast
since day one you remember you chewing
the cables I do I was just going to
bring it up man back in the day this was
still dig era I guess and we were at
your apartment in San Francisco and he
was just a little pup chewing on the
cables I remember
that yeah he's still kicking it though
he's still mentally he's sharp as
which great which is like nice you yeah
it was nice to see him I remember
playing with him Friendly Toast yeah
what a great dog yeah so for me
I it's it's hard for me to imagine a
world or any circumstances in which I
would regret having the paw prints on on
the arm and there are many other how
much has that dog meant for you
personally because like I've seen you
through multiple relationships yeah dogs
are like this thing that is just like
this steadfast love Yeah like has it
been a a good like I mean obviously it's
been it must been insane emotional if
for you to have a animal like that in
your life yeah it's it's changed me
fundamentally on so many different ways
I think and it's not just the receipt of
that love which is it's like a task in
it of itself right I mean like to and I
and I I actually saw this at one point
somebody had sketched it on to this
piece of wood and I came across it and
it was like your task in life is to
learn how to love and be loved like
that's it and being loved is actually
not straightforward for everyone MH
right learning to receive that in a way
so that has been a gift but it's also
been a practice of giving and thinking
about someone else's welfare
and having say a dog as a mirror also
for yourself where let's just say early
on
when I was training Molly I took
training super seriously God I was there
for that yeah and serious and I was I
ended up being pretty good at it and
Molly's very well
trained but if she up or made a
mistake I would I would get upset yeah
and you hit her no Jesus Christ I did
not hit my dog and beat her with a
rod uh so no I wouldn't hit Molly but I
would get I would get very very
frustrated and then that would scare her
and not because I was flashing out but I
would just get so frustrated because i'
be like God this this 37th time we've
done this and it was a mirror because
Molly's not doing anything deliberately
to piss me off that's ridiculous it was
an incredible reflection in the pond for
me to see what was going on and to see
what's going on with me right like if
I'm short-tempered
if you're with other people you can
weave a story to justify it right well
like they should know like God I didn't
get any sleep and they know that
and why does it always have to be in the
morning that they blah blah blah you can
you can really Spin A Yarn MH to
rationalize why you're upset with
someone else but a really loving well-
behaved dog are you kidding like that's
a you problem pal like that is not a dog
problem yeah and so on all of those
levels she's just been such a wonderful
companion and teacher and I was away
from her for a few weeks recently for
the first time because I was in South
America and absolutely not the right
place for a dog where I was in the
middle of the Jungle and I really really
missed her so I mean God I'm going to
really like take us there but like when
I think about which I do pretty often
like when she has her Decline and then
passes like it's heartbreaking for me to
imagine and I'm going to get a second
dog almost certainly in the next year
that would be on my nearest resolutions
too and I've thought about this for a
few years but I've pushed it off because
there's part of me that doesn't want to
accept that Molly is
Mortal so I pushed it off and push it
off but it it's it's time it's good to
do it on the sooner side because when
they're older like I could never
introduce another dog to toaster right
now yeah cuz he's just too old to handle
that puppy energy yeah versus if you did
it now then they can kind of and Molly's
really good with puppies and she loves
puppies so I'm going to do that very
soon uh in the next year and I at one
point was volunteering it's a long story
but I was volunteering around wolves and
I was like preparing the food and so on
for these wolves which were those the
ones that licked you in the teeth and
stuff yeah which were being sort of
rehabilitated and raised in captivity
because they had either been bred and
raised in captivity in which case they
can't be released or there any number of
conditions that led to them being
nonviable as wild releases I saw one of
the volunteers had I think it was on his
rib cage he had a print from this wolf
that he had known for years until that
wolf passed away and I thought to myself
you know what I've never felt pulled to
have a tattoo and the fact that I have
no tattoos is kind of Novel now which is
funny right like like tattoos are pretty
common oh you got to go to Jess my my
lady she's amazing so I might I might
and I thought you know I really have a
hard time I'm
imagining regretting doing that and I
can also see it being a really valuable
reminder of a lot Tim I've got something
for you listen to this tell me you know
how I said someone was going to play at
my birthday like Jess is going to be out
there at the same time okay why don't
you sign up to get the tattoo at the
party I mean not at the party but like
the day before the day after or
something like that and she is like
booked out by like a year like she did
Bruce wills's tattoos like she's like
no she's like legit as they count she's
legit okay all right J Jess machete on
Instagram like uh insane all right now
she's booked out for five years I
just just string this this has been on
my list for a while it's been on my list
for a couple years and I think partially
because I'm nervous you would you would
love her can I ask you a question yeah I
want to ask you a question that is a
little bit more intimate just because
we've had some tequila and um uh we're
talking about dogs and and just kind of
the companionship and and what
M speaking of kind of like New Year's
resolutions and looking back on life in
the last 10 years when it comes to both
personal intimate like relationships or
private what would you if there's any
one thing what would you change about
your interactions with either someone
that you've been with on an intimate
level or someone that like maybe it's
like on a more kind of like you know
friendship level is there anything that
you can look back on and say I would
have done more of this that is an
exceptional question and you know when I
was driving over here I was thinking
about another question we have the
ultimate Cliffhanger in the crazy drug
story so maybe we'll get to that maybe
we won't maybe we'll do that the next
episode but I was thinking also I was
like what would Kevin tell his I'm going
to ask your question but I was thinking
what would Kevin tell his 30-year-old
self my current Kevin like do this maybe
not do so much of that blah blah blah
thought that could be fun exploration
with the interpersonal stuff I think
that I would say just because someone
needs other things things that are
different from your needs does not make
them high maintenance and by the way Tim
if they looked at you through the same
lens you were looking at them through
they would decide that you were high
mantenance so gather some tools right I
would say read the five love languages
as cheesy and schlocky as it might seem
that is so helpful as a framework
for discussion mhm for identifying and
easily labeling the different categories
of needs that people might have and
putting them in some type of order oh
interesting you're a quality time person
good to know number two would be this oh
you're a physical touch and then acts of
service person as I am right like these
are shared vocabulary that you can use
to really avoid and repair a lot of
things right so I would say handful of
things right so gay and Katy hendris
also like conscious loving there are
there are a few books a few resources I
would say look if you really care about
someone commit together to develop a
short hand which allows you
to not necessarily prevent I don't think
prevention is the key I think repair is
the key right like if you're in a
startup and you're like well let's just
prevent all the bad things from
happening that's never going to work
right shit's going to happen and people
are going to have bad days and you're
going to say things you regret and they
going to be
disagreements and by the way if there
are no disagreements something's wrong
right right 100% And therefore having a
shorthand and a set of agreements right
like the these are the rules that we
agree to play by and we're not going to
be perfect I would say that would be
very high on the list and I would say
for really close relationships it
potentially maybe we'll edit this out
but who knows MDMA assisted
Psychotherapy let's just say anywhere
from Once a quarter to once a year no
more than once a quarter for a whole
host of reasons but I I think that while
MDMA assisted Psychotherapy for PTSD is
incredibly impressive and I've been very
involved with that from I don't want to
say day one cuz that's not true but
certainly for the last 10 years or so
I've been very involved up through phase
3 and and now onward the results with
treatment resistant PTSD a complex PTSD
where you see people who have had this
diagnosis for 17 years suddenly after
two or three sessions end up
asymptomatic right they would not meet
the criteria for PTSD right with
durability out to 6 9 12 months it's
something that almost defies belief
right it it is causing a complete
reexamination of Psychiatry as we know
it I still think that is second place to
coup's work when it comes to MDMA I
think that that is that is an incredibly
fruitful arena for seeeing the full
potential of MDMA assist psychotherapies
that that would be another one because
sometimes often times couples end up and
I know multiple people now who have had
this experience with professional
guidance which by the way folks
currently is legal so before warrant
there are legal consequences or at least
risks entailed with this not to mention
the fact that at least I would say 60 to
70% of MDMA that you might purchase is
is adulterated or mixed with something
else at this point so you need to be
very careful dancesafe.org is a resource
I would recommend for testing kits and
so on if you're going to go that route
I'm not recommending you do anything
illegal however people are going to do
it anyway International listen people
are going to people are people are going
to do it anyway I I I just recognize
it's like you can't just say to every
teenager like don't have sex like kids
are going to have sex so let's be
realistic about it I did that one
time it's fun as had sex
no no I did when I 23 I did uh I did
well they were kind of ecstasy back then
but like holy that is a compound
yeah and that can go that can also go
sideways just for for record yeah so
like there are films out there now how
to change your mind the miner on Netflix
watch the nbma episode it is excellent
yeah and it's pretty heavy because it
gets into some PTSD but you'll be able
to see live session footage if you want
another alternative or compliment he's
great and there is also a dock called
trip of compassion which is worth seeing
which has a lot of session footage as
well but those are a few of the things
that would come to mind and I would say
on a friendship level I might suggest to
my earlier self let's just say
30-year-old self
right something that I have really
embraced and put into action in the last
handful of years which is going to sound
a little antisocial but I don't view it
that way humans have a finite capacity
for building and sustaining really deep
relationships you just can't do that
with everyone and when I've looked back
say and I do this every year at a past
year review right I look back at my my
calendar every week of my last year and
on a piece of paper with positive and
negative two columns I write down the
peak and Peak negative and positive
experiences if I look at the
commonalities is for the peak positive
experiences It's usually the same 10
people or fewer right it's the same cast
of characters these are my close friends
who are nourishing supportive good
influence and before what I would say to
my younger self is before you seek to
develop a bunch of new relationships ask
yourself are you spending enough time as
much time as you would like with the
people on that short list who you know
are guaranteed to be nourishing for you
and if the answer is no maybe you should
double down on those relationships maybe
you should reach out to those people to
get something on the calendar before
crowds it out before you look for
shiny objects MH in new relationships
which doesn't mean I don't develop new
relationships I occasionally do but I'm
at a point where I think recognizing the
ephemeral nature of Life the the finite
limits the constraints that we have is
actually very enabling it helps you to
make cleaner faster decisions so for me
I would just say
before seeking to develop new deep
relationships ask yourself the question
for my closest Five friends let's just
say in the last year did I spend as much
time as I would like with those people
and if the answer is no reach out to
this five first yeah yeah what about you
oh man I would say honestly I think that
we're at the age now where every day
just brings uh a new unknown in terms of
like how long are we going to last I've
had multiple friends with cancer now I
had one friend that I almost lost this
year that was in in the you know
emergency room for weeks that we thought
had stage four cancer and ended up being
a horrible uh bacterial infection from
some foreign country
and it's
just I just I just realized like you
know there's so many times when we hang
out and we and we just you know give a
hug and say oh good to see you like blah
blah but we don't say I love you you
know we don't say you know I you are so
essential to me in so many ways and may
maybe this is the the ketamine talking
but like no but when I went through this
whole thing with aaman therapy I
realized like at the end of the day love
is the this going to sound cheesy but it
is like it is the most important thing
that we tell each other and that we feel
for each other and like when you can
really feel that and you say this person
is like so important I mean you let them
know that and you feel it back I don't
know what what's better than that you
know yeah yeah what's more human than
that too right yeah in a way I mean like
love you know you can observe affection
and love in in many other species but
the ability to verbalize it and express
it yeah do you feel that psychedelics
brings that out of you because like when
I did the the the therapy I I had more
love in me than I've had in so long MH
do you feel that's a a commonality
amongst like psychedelics to to like
have a sense of just gratitude for
existence for sure I think it's I think
it's very common it's it's not always
across the board I mean I would say that
this might be a controversial statement
but the psychedelics to me are similar
to there's a lot more to it which we'll
probably dive into but kind of like
alcohol or power or money in the sense
that they magnify what's already
there and they term you sometimes here
is a non-specific amplifier so I don't
think that at all there's no compelling
evidence to me that psychedelics if put
in the drinking water produce World
piece there's no evidence for that right
I mean you have plenty of civilizations
maybe lithium though no no no remember
there was a I remember I remember yeah a
little bit of lithium goes a long way
yeah yeah people can look this up we'll
try to find there are some there's a
study that that people in populations
where there is more lithium naturally
found in the drinking water have lower
rates of suicide than anywhere else in
all sorts of stuff yeah so we'll see
what we can find to put in the show
notes I do think lowd dose lithium is
pretty interesting very low dose
psychedelics are nonspecific amplifier
there are many cases of civilizations
where they had Human Sacrifice played
soccer with human heads and they consume
psychedelics I still sacrifice people
yeah yeah like you know as we all do you
know every once in a while on the
solstice I mean it's I think it's all
fair game but the feeling of gratitude
and love I think for a lot of people who
wish to enable that to experience it
more who have the conscious or
subconscious desire to rekindle those
things the experience you're describing
is very common yeah for sure and I think
part of that is the dissolution this
isn't true of all experiences but the
dissolution of self and consequently the
the felt sense of unity with many or all
things which leads you to feel for most
people less alone yeah which leads you
to feel quite grateful because to State
the obvious I suppose I mean the despite
the fact that we're more connected than
ever with loose I think a lot of people
suffer from anxiety and depression that
is highly correlated to a feeling of
isolation so when you can remedy that by
feeling the exact polar opposite in some
of these states not necessary but
helpful that the the end result of that
is is a feeling of gratitude for sure
awesome yeah what what was the um before
we wrap things up because I know we're
coming to the end and you still have
some to finish what was the Cliffhanger
you said you wanted to you want to tell
us yeah so I'll I'll try to keep it
short I mean I'll let you I'll tell you
what I'll keep it short and then you can
excavate okay as you like I'd love to
excavate all right so as you know for
the last year I've basically been
crippled by lowback issues I mean i'
I've had trouble there are days when
I've had trouble getting up and walking
I mean it's been that bad yeah I mean to
be honest Tim you first told me about
this like 8 years ago or something
remember when you got those injections
or something
like you like I think I have
degenerative dis disease yeah so I've
had lower back issues for a long time
this is also a congenital issue so I
have what's called a uh transitional
segment in other words the there's a
segment in my lumbar there vertebrae in
my lumbar area that really mimic a
sacral vertebral uh segment and that's
problematic for a host of reasons
creates an abnormal angle and if you can
imagine just bending the paper clip over
and over again in ways that it shouldn't
be bent that's sort of the feeling in
the lowb back and my brother has this
there are other people in my family who
have this issue so standing extended
slow walking like a museum walk cocktail
party type of experience can be very
painful like the low back locks up but
in the last year specifically had all
sorts of issues and all sorts of MRIs
and Specialists and PT and adjustments
and traction and this that and the other
thing and it was a disaster and it
caused it well let me give myself a
little more agency I created a lot of
anxiety around this cuz I was like
is this the new normal right is is this
really The New Normal where well cuz you
you project forward like what what is 5
years from now look like yeah I'm like
I'm not that old right you know and I'm
pretty active and your skinc care is
amazing my skincare is amazing I saw
your in
boy you know what's funny sidebar is how
much time you can spend on like a blog
post takes six months to put together
and it's like you get like crickets and
a fart in the wind and then nobody ever
reads it again and then someone in your
team is like you know what people ask
about your skincare let's grab a couple
clips and throw it up and it goes
bananas I'm on I'm on Instagram and the
first thing that pops up to me is like
hi I'm Tim Ferris people ask me about my
skincare regimen let me tell you I use
bronners natural soap what like I like
what the is come into yeah so here
we are here we are folks your skin looks
amazing though breathaking coming back
to the the main through line here
terrifying experience with the back and
I I had more or less given up I was I
was in the stage of grief where I was
trying to get past denial and accept
that this might be the new normal
because no one could figure it out and a
lot lot of the advice I received many of
the diagnoses were conflicting and then
decided in part because of this to do a
few things and part of that was going to
South America which I'm not recommending
there are a lot of risks down in South
America it's generally like safety fifth
it's not safety first so people get into
a lot of trouble but I went down and did
this did this training which involved
consuming a bunch of plants also
involved fasting for a week also
involved wait wait wait water fast water
fast Jesus s days yeah also involved
during that week really not sitting and
standing very little so he's either
hammock or cot basically and I'm
mentioning these things because they're
confounders Translating that into basic
English that means that I can't really
point back to one thing and say this is
what caused what I'm going to
describe but the during the first
experience which happened to be with
iasa which is a huge gun it's I think
treated very casually by people who do
not realize what they're signing up for
I do not recommend it to most people as
my ex who's going to become relevant in
a second would tell you I talk many many
many more people nine out of 10 which X
Out of I'm not going to mention her name
but out my most recent X Out of using
iasa then I talk into using iasa like
nine times out of 10 I say you should
not proceed do not pass go for a lot of
reasons but in this particular case
had a very very very difficult
experience uh and I can kind of rank
order my hardest experiences over the
last you know decade plus and this would
be the third most difficult maybe the
second for different characteristics
which is saying a lot and there was a
point at which in that experience all I
could imagine was having my head in the
lap of my ex like that's all I wanted it
was the only thing I could even
visualize because I was in the Impact
Zone I was just getting hit by 100 foot
waves from every angle and there was no
respite it was 10 out of 10 there was no
wave meaning it didn't EB and flow it
was just 10 out of 10 volume from Peak
until end of the night effectively it
was it was unusual and Incredibly
difficult that was true for everyone in
the session your Shaman mixed the wrong
this guy's famous for having a brew that
just cripples cripples people and like
like yeah I mean there are a lot of
other full-time clinicians from
indigenous Traditions who will not drink
his Brew I'll put it that way oh Jesus
and coming back to the point of the
story I'm imagining you know the only
thing I can Envision is is this
woman holding my head and consoling me
that's the only thing I can imagine and
then I
realized that for a year because we
separated a bit over a year
ago and this was totally subconscious
right it wasn't a decision on my part
but I realized I had not allowed myself
to
feel the
complete
obliterating
heartbreak that was in
fact the core response to that
separation right like I'd not allowed
myself to her or from previous from that
separation right like in other words my
psyche had seemingly protected me
because of my history of depression
right which i' I've I've come to manage
better than ever before like each year
I'm better able to manage it and it's
less and less frequent it's less and
less intense but nonetheless let's face
the facts in college I almost killed
myself right so there's a there was a
fear at least
subconsciously that because of this
separation because of starting over it
at square one that I could spiral into a
deep depression and that could be
dangerous so my psyche protect protected
me from that by not letting me feel the
sadness the pain to the extent that
ended up being important which I
realized in this moment so I allowed
myself to soak in it in that moment I
trip reports are so boring most
of the time and I apologize to people
who might be listening and thinking oh
here we go again because I get it trust
me but in this particular case I
experienced something I've never
experienced as soon as I soaked in that
and I really soaked in it and it was
awful it was so dark and so heavy and
[Music]
then I felt my back release and
literally I've been 90 plus% painfree
since that moment and it blows
my mind because at that point I couldn't
explain it with the fast because the
fast and ketones are highly
anti-inflammatory and I think that they
actually played a role hold on in the
durability of things but the fact that
there was an immediate release I was
going to say interesting it is is
interesting I can't explain that through
fasting I can't explain that through the
just being recumbent right laying down
for 7 days because that was yet to come
and I would say that I made a a tactical
error in the last few weeks which is I
was like man like I'm all good and
so I've neglected some of the basic
self-care and strengthening and PT which
I think is important because my low back
and and so on which are some of the
surrounding muscles have atrophied over
the last year of avoiding working with
the back there was that experience and
for people who may be interested in
delving into this a little bit more
there is a book I don't agree with
everything in the book but it is
interesting in the sense that it was
written by a western trained MD who
ended up then opening a healing clinic
in South America focused on iOS in diets
which you will read about if you get
into the book called The Fellowship of
the river so I found that book quite
interesting on a number of levels but
the reason I bring this all up number
one people had recommended this book I
think it's called healing low back pain
I may be getting the title slightly
wrong it could be fixing low back pain
but it's by Dr Sarno John Sarno and this
book was recommended to me I've read it
before and the the general gist is it's
all in your head now I took great
offense at parts of this book and a lot
of it is scientifically indefensible so
he unfortunately I threw the baby out
with the bath water a bit because he
sends a he says a bunch of things that
are
ridiculous and you know he he cites
these success statistics for his method
while s simultaneously saying if I
interview someone and they say they're
not open to a or c i omit them from my
treatment and I'm like okay well wait a
second your selection is out of
control I wanted to bring this up
because that book has has helped a lot
of people despite its flaws and not
everyone will at any point want to
consume iasa which I would advise
against for 90 plus% of the population
uh because it can be very destabilizing
for a lot of people and very risky I
would say there are a lot of things you
should do beforehand right like try the
talk therapy try holotropic breath work
consider after speaking of doct ketamine
after that you can consider other tools
um but iasa should be like let's do
fifth on your let's do random show on
iwasa we could do that possible yeah
possibly yeah iasa would be like fifth
or sixth on the list of progressions it
would not be first uh but I would say
the Saro books are interesting I know
they've helped people like Brian cman
who's been on the podcast amazing writer
who was co- creator of billions among
others rounders
Etc and it's it's something that I've
always in theory agreed with yes we
store stress that can have a
physiological effect there are
autoimmune disorders that I think are
intimately linked with different types
of psychological disturbances so you can
address the problem kind of from the
physiological side first of course the
brain isn't entirely separate there's no
kind of cartisian separation of mind and
body so yes the brain is physiological
but you can you can attack it through
content in a way or you can attack it
through Pharmaceuticals and Physiology
first I think you can go both ways but
the the Saro book I think is worth a lot
of people reading the second thing I'll
mention which is very very simple and
tactical if you have lower back pain I'm
shocked took me this long to figure it
out and say sitting on Hard chairs
bothers you or Lum lumbar support helps
you
for a year I've been going to
restaurants and asking if they have a
cushion do you have a cushion or a
pillow or something I can use to fix
up seating situations this is the
solution right here this is it this is a
Pilates ball this is a prob body Pilates
doesn't really matter but honestly this
thing folds up six in your pocket and
I've been traveling with it I've had it
behind my back the whole time and like
great for First Dates great for First
Dates ladies love Pilates balls and I
but I will say for instance like the
last time I did a podcast in this seat I
did not use this and my back was
killing me afterwards but the killing me
afterwards is not just an issue for
today that's an issue that causes
inflammation that up my sleep for
three or 4 days use this ball no problem
I can put it behind my back or I can put
it under my ass and it it folds up and
fits in your pocket so anyway folks
there you have it from the L to the
ridiculous Pilates ball
amazing all right how we doing any other
topics I I mean I feel I feel pretty
good next time we'll get to what you
would tell your 30-year-old self
anything you'd like to add in that
category uh no I just you know I think
if we're are we wrapping up now cuz I'd
like to say some wrapping up comments
wrapping up comments please yeah so my
wrapping up comments would be this I
recently went out to dinner with five
close friends of mine who of which you
know most of them just like the crew GL
yeah just good friends and one of the
things I did is I I went around the
circle and I said a few words of
gratitude and I think to my earlier
point one of the things that's really
important to me after coming out of this
therapy is just this vulnerability that
allows us to speak from the heart
because we don't know what tomorrow
brings and I just want to say that Tim
you have been a friend of mine for so
long now and I have
appreciated the fact that my career has
been a series of ups and downs and all
over the place and you have been a
steadfast friend someone that sends me
some of the funniest videos I've ever
seen in my life always keeps it like
light-hearted and fun but I know that
you care deeply about me and I just want
to let you know that I love you and I
care deeply about you and and I will
always be here to have your back and I'm
wishing you a fantastic New Year I hope
that you hit all these milestones and
more that you want to hit because I know
that you are someone that I've always
looked up to and someone that is just so
inspirational to us all that listen to
your show and your podcast because you
inspire us to do more and to be better
humans and I just want to let you know
that that's that means a lot to me and I
love you well thanks Kevin
that's amazing that makes my night and
happy to say it yeah it's the truth I
love you too man it's our friendship has
been such a such a constant for
me such
a Lifeline in a way with all the ups and
downs and holy I mean both of us
have had some pretty wly ups and downs
you've had a lot of hot chicks you did I
didn't see that coming yeah well you
talked about the upside down I like you
got a up my friend yeah I mean yeah i'
look that's in one category that's in
one category had to lighten up the mood
a little bit and I'm and I'm and I'm
grateful for that and uh you know life
is like a box of chocolates right you
just never know what's around the corner
it's true and it's true that's why it's
important to say these things you know
it is it is and you know I have I have
I'll tell you something you don't know I
have your Christmas SL New Year's card
from like two years ago so obviously out
a date it's like you and Daria and the
kids and it's up in my kitchen amazing
and I kept it there because I just I
love seeing you guys every day and I
think about you guys all the time and
just have such love for your family and
I'm so grateful for our friendships I
love you too man it's important to say
things are so uncertain and I've never
experienced I've had friends pass from
cancer for yeah but I've never been with
them through I've I've never been there
every step of the way from diagnosis to
last conversation a few days before they
passed that was new for me yeah and it
affected really deeply affected me on a
bunch of
levels and I want to be deeply affected
by that right I I I want I don't want to
push that aside in part because Roland
was
so joyful and
curious and optimistic until the end in
a very genuine way I it wasn't an act it
wasn't
theater that raised a bunch of
aspirations in me right because he was
first and foremost a very dedicated
season
meditator psychedelics were a piece of
the puzzle but first and foremost he was
a dedicated meditator for decades that's
amazing and attributed a lot of his
equinity
and preparation for death which I got to
see firsthand a lot of people talk about
it right but let's be honest or I'll be
honest I've read all the stoics or a lot
of the stoics and I've read all sorts of
Buddhism
and rehearsed death and momentto mor and
this that and the other thing but when
I'm actually on as Roland said the final
Glide path I don't know how I'm going to
respond I don't know I have no idea so
to see someone who really like walked
the walk
in such a life affirming way that Lit
everyone up around him was was
tremendous and he said what he was able
to and he was willing to say what he
meant to those people around him who
meant things to
him and you don't have to wait until you
have terminal cancer diagnosis you
shouldn't wait just because it it may
not be that right it may be a car crash
it may be something where you don't get
the chance to say these things and so I
just yeah it's important to do it now
yeah you got to do it great to see you
man yeah good to see you all right man
happy New Year excited for this is going
to be a oh don't you me off a little bit
cheers yeah cheers um to to the new year
and and to all the listeners out there
you know wishing you a happy and healthy
New Year and yeah I'm excited to
continue this new I mean it's always a a
new year of change a new year change and
exploration I think the one thing that
you and I let's take a sip the one thing
that you and I have in common is just
this like lifelong pursuit of of
evolution yeah of of like figuring out
because there the the secret that no one
will tell you is no matter how much
money you make no matter how much
success you have we're all still
figuring out and in ROM doss's words
we're all just walking each other home
well said man I'm going to leave leave
it there here we go cheers buddy happy
New Year happy early New Year and happy
New Year to everybody
listening and as always be just a little
Kinder than is necessary until the next
episode that applies to other people but
also applies to yourself take it easy
take it easy you know life is short but
life is long and we're all just figuring
it out and by the way as far as I can
tell you never really figure it out no
you don't
true so so true ctfo chill the out
a little bit be a little easier on
yourself and we'll put everything in the
show notes tnd Blog podcast for all the
stuff we talked about Kevin rose.com is
a better website Kevin rose.com be sure
to check out this amazing new podcast
after new podcast Kevin r. is the best
place to go forget. blog and uh and keev
Kev Kev talk talk coming at you soon
thanks for listening everybody bye see
you